Worst intro.
Remember,
could you imagine?
He's fucking cones.
So stupid.
The people who stupid that listen,
but just being quiet.
Does her keys topic,
was it out right now?
Yeah,
we don't live in,
but the whole thing's happening.
Yeah.
Ah,
it's all going on right now,
ladies and gentlemen.
Our Recia fee or is all up in this bitch.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is
brought to you by the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click
on the link and answering the code name
Rogan,
you will get 15% off.
Ari,
I have one for you.
If you want a new shipment in,
I hear they're wonderful.
It's also brought to you by Alpha brain.
Alpha brain is a cognitive enhancer sold
by [inaudible] Dot com o n n I t.com
and I use it and Brian uses it.
We're going to get Arriana too and it
has its detractors like all wonderful
things,
but may have Miller is a
big fucking fan really.
And Yeah,
and if you go to Joe Rogan,
Nanette and click on the audit,
like enter and Rogan,
10% off that too.
How many tractors I've used that present
was very few people are nonbelievers.
They want to believe
in the placebo effect.
Maybe
shit for results,
placebo or not.
I'm in this shit for results.
Give me a Hologram,
cock ring and let me think that this
shit makes my dick work better and it
probably will make my dick work better
on placebo just like everybody else.
We're,
we're fucking dumb,
you know.
Um,
did I tell you about
the study on placebos?
You did.
And that's one of the reasons
why I brought that up.
It's really just a hair.
Yeah.
It's brilliant.
It's a bro Tell Mpr it's,
you know,
it's real.
Um,
they did a study
on a,
on just placebo effects per se,
so that gave people what they
told them was the placebo.
They were in the control group,
um,
for a,
a low blood pressure or heart medication,
something like that.
Um,
but they told him we're only giving
you a placebo and it's still affected.
Our blood pressure went down
in the people noticeably like,
yeah,
yeah.
Like measurably,
they think that it has something to do
with just concentrating on whatever it is
and or ritualistic thing.
I'm concentrating on it every day.
One of the ladies in the study,
like after it ended,
she was like,
oh,
that's great,
but I need more of that.
Like my blood pressure is lower,
don't drop me.
I want lower blood pressure.
Like,
can I get as you wouldn't be out,
she couldn't get placebos at rite aid.
That's so crazy.
Yeah.
How weird is the human brain
and what the hell is going on?
Just some sort of regularity helps you,
I dunno.
Yeah.
Thinking about all the time you will,
there's a dude who was going to
come on the podcast and talk about,
his name is Bruce Lipton
and he wrote a book,
uh,
on that very subject.
Really?
Yeah.
He,
um,
he wrote,
it's called the biology of
belief and I ran into his,
uh,
I believe it's his cousin at one of the
shows and the guy gave me that book and
then he contacted me on Twitter and
he's going to come on and explain to us,
and he's a scientist so he'll,
you know,
the break,
I believe he's a scientist.
He'll be able to break it
down and explain exactly.
You know,
what the fuck they believe is going on.
And like with the human brain.
Yeah.
In terms of,
you know,
understandable that you and I will be
able to grab the reasonably educated
people to be able to grab,
but the idea is really strange,
you know?
Yeah.
You can fool yourself
into having a real hope.
It's so bizarre that we somehow or another
have little triggers in our body that
we don't know how to push the road stuff.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Like when someone gets caught under a car,
Why can all of a sudden you throw
that fucking car off person,
but by the way,
they can,
man,
people can do crazy shit.
But I said that's cause
the release of adrenaline.
Yeah.
Gas I guess.
But also,
you know a lot of what you can't lift
is cause you're not willing to tolerate
the pain.
You know when you're,
when you're trying to pick
up something really heavy,
it's very painful.
Your body's sending you a lot of signals
and most of those signals are uh,
listen,
listen is not a good thing to do.
Okay,
let's stop.
This is heavy.
What the fuck?
This hurts.
Okay,
we're going to drop this.
I'm telling you right now
But when your baby's
trapped under your car,
all those don't make it.
They're like the only thing that saved
the baby and your body just goes into
full crazy gorilla mode.
We tried to lift the car off train tracks
at Bridgetown Portland Burstein and
comedy festivals here.
Really to see if he could do it.
We took a wrong,
oh no,
I only got stuck on the
tracks and he went for it.
And you just started skidding cause
it looks like you can drive over the,
the the,
the stone part,
you know right outside the tracks.
But that drops down so you
would just start sliding.
Wow.
The wheels make no connection.
So we had like 12 comics try to
lift this car off the tracks.
We get back it up.
We couldn't do it.
He couldn't even get close.
We took like one tire up.
Like I don't,
I can't imagine some lady
picking the car up off her kid.
I want to see it.
Why is there an opinion?
Well there's probably a video
on youtube or something.
Oh God,
I wouldn't be able to watch it.
Would you be able to watch that amongst
younger woman to try to pick a baby?
That would be way too emotional for me.
You know,
if there's that video though power,
which is sponsored power,
a I that would work,
that would help you rehydrate after
lifting a baby or a car off a baby tired
would give you a special strength.
It is weird how some people would just
have way more physical strength than
others.
It's so clear that we're
in some weird phase,
you know,
like very few animals I think vary in
size and shape as much as people do.
The only thing that's close,
I think his dogs and you know,
by the way,
they don't know where
the fuck dogs come from.
Really don't have a goddamn clue.
Well,
this is one of the things they found out
when they mapped the genome of the dog.
They thought that it was
going to be wolves and a
bunch of different wild canids
and coyotes and all this
different chicken on.
No,
no,
no.
It's all walls.
It's all wove.
All Wolf so that when they just bread it,
just like they've read them now,
they don't have a fucking
clue.
No one has ever been able to
go from wolf to Chihuahua ever.
No one's ever documented,
hey,
I'm going to take this wolf
and turn it into Chihuahua.
It's one of those things we accept
that we don't understand it.
It's been around for so long.
It's clearly genetic manipulation.
Egypt,
yes,
that cats,
we know they had cats.
I think they had dogs,
but there's no indication of whether or
not they had the variation of dogs that
we have today.
We have a weird variation,
a little tiny things that are useless.
I mean,
you know cute pets and shit,
but big ones.
They're guard dogs,
work dogs,
dogs for hunting.
So many distinctions.
Arizona.
Just see the wild dogs,
the really,
really,
that's scary shit.
They don't really attack
people that I've seen.
They're just sort of like bare.
There was a story in Georgia a few years
back about some wild dogs that killed a
man.
Really?
Yeah.
I shouldn't do that.
Well,
they get to,
I mean they get to packs and then they
all grow up generation after generation
in the woods.
You know,
all you need is a couple of generations
and you're dealing with a fucking killer
animal out there.
That's a scary fucking thing.
And they'd take out a dear,
why wouldn't they take out you
if you're alone by yourself?
And there's like 30 of them and
that's how they're traveling.
Like grizzly man.
Oh,
you finally start.
And that's the same feeling I got.
I was like,
dude,
if they're eating their young,
what did you make the connection to food?
Awesome.
That was the most ridiculous guy ever.
It's crazy.
I don't understand how
he couldn't see that,
but he's like,
oh,
they're eating themselves well hungry.
He was just so gay that he
was just running away from it.
He was running away from the gayness to
the point where he decided to live alone
in the woods with monsters.
Big,
giant,
ridiculous.
They're like rats,
like giant rats sort of bear as well.
I'm a peaceful right next to
him and then they just too.
How about the video where he had one
bear who had his back up against a tree?
He was like scratching his back.
So he's standing full up and scratching
his back and he's like fucking feet
tall.
And could you imagine this asshole is
just sleeping in the bushes with a piece
of fabric over his head
for years and years.
Wow.
Yeah,
but will he fucked up as he stayed to la?
He stayed to the point
where they were super,
super desperate.
The those fall bears.
Why do you think he stayed
longer than suicide by bear?
For sure.
Yeah,
he's massively depressed.
That guy was crazy.
If you see how he gets in front of the
camera and starts screaming and the
fucking government bears,
that guy's manic and there's he's,
I think he was trying to commit suicide.
Yeah.
In a sense.
He went back when he had nothing else.
That's when he went back.
He went back to the,
to the Alaska to that,
that area every year.
Where Al Yeah,
but he didn't go back this late.
We went back in late October
and in November that's
when the bears are going to
sleep.
And so the only bears that are up
are the bears that were unsuccessful.
They didn't know the old ones.
They're dying.
And that's what happens man.
They die
and we don't even know.
We don't,
we very,
very rarely find bare bones.
It's really kinda interesting.
You know,
bears are massive animals.
One of the babies only just as bear skull,
the white,
and they'll probably eat that later and
it wasn't coming back Kilbane within a
few days ago.
And I'm like,
well,
they eat their bones.
They eat,
they eat their dead bodies.
They the,
the bear that killed this guy,
they shot it and killed it and they came
back like two weeks later and it was
just everything gone.
Just a few bones scattered around.
It felt like rib bones or this is
really [inaudible] most of the bones,
they had most of everything.
The chicken at Hardee's there,
weather bears,
man bears are big fucking animals.
You know,
I don't think we can even wrap
our heads around what that is.
It's a big building machine and people
just sleep near him when those two bears
were fighting and the ones shit himself.
Yeah.
How crazy was that?
Great footage?
That was amazing footage.
Amazing footage.
No one else would be
that crazy right there.
And they're really trying
to kill each other.
Yeah.
It's an amazing fight.
Would always talking about between
these two bears on this like beach,
right?
He was like,
yeah,
the shore of a lake or
something like that.
We're in a field and lit
or something like that.
Yeah.
Water right.
That scene.
Big scene,
going out,
partying,
trying to bite each other.
Like it looks like the death to death
for sure on the eye and ear out.
Oh,
they're trying to fuck each other up.
It's over.
Who gets to fuck?
I guess that's what it is,
man.
That's how they decide.
That's how does it
decide who gets to fuck.
That's why I don't
participate in that at bars,
when I see another guy
get involved with a check,
I'm heading out.
I'm like,
I'm out.
I'll see you guys later.
Smart.
That's a healthy way of
one things for a chance.
Goodnight.
Yeah.
And then dudes will get douchey with you.
Like you're like,
Whoa,
settle down.
I don't even know you.
You're not even,
we were so used to all be,
you know,
men out here having fun.
They're not really angry.
Really snapping.
Yeah,
you're really turning on me like that.
You're the problem dude.
You know,
if,
if the world was filled with cool people,
partying would be the shit you know of.
The world was filled with people
who could hold their liquor,
keep their weed under wraps.
And when you went out,
everybody was cool and everybody
was friendly to everybody.
You don't have to worry,
but it's those fucking few douche bags.
Well you like this
fucking queer knowing me,
it's fucking Jew.
Has anyone ever called you a fucking Jew?
Angrily?
I don't know about angrily online.
Yeah,
online
last night was these two guys came
up to me the store and they're like,
oh we're fans of yours and the Rogan
podcast and your podcast and stuff.
But I was like,
oh thanks.
And,
and Don bears just nearing like,
cause by just like,
and they're like,
what?
What's it matter goes,
you know,
you're talking to a Jew,
right?
Are you familiar?
Did he warn you?
Did he give you ample
opportunity to get away
and lost her laughing?
I was in the parking lot in a,
in West hills of all places
and I go to the parking lot.
It was a truck there with these white
skulls on it and I at it and it's like
some shit written and gothic
letter and it says white power,
white power.
Just guy just had this on his car.
Is it a movie?
Wow.
Ooh,
no,
no.
It was just out doing it out.
Yup.
It was on the back windows of his truck.
It's a white power and I was like,
whoa dude.
It's funny though living in the city
because there is movie prop cars I see all
the time cause I live in Burbank.
I saw like an action news car.
The other one like Whoa,
that's a,
that's a really cheesy news van.
And it was just from
the new screen movie or
fake newspapers.
Yeah,
where the news,
they've been pull up with
a satellite on the roof.
Yeah.
It's funny how,
I mean all those action newspeople like
if you watch like any of those action
newspeople are any of those
e entertainment people,
they're just interchangeable.
To me they're just,
they're just a delivery device.
They're not even a human being turned on
every once in a while a while and I'll
see a new girl.
Oh she's pretty and they,
here we come.
Brad Pitt says Jeff ran us,
didn't have stuff,
still remained friends
after all these years.
And it's the same human being that's
really low frequency projection devices
that are disguised as
human beings and they just,
they're the same person that hired that,
that rock band guy once.
Yes.
Mark McGwire Martin.
No,
no,
no.
It's a guy from Mark Mcgrath.
Mark Mcgrath showed us
a little about sports.
It goes pretty sure I'm right.
That guy.
Yeah,
he was doing,
he was doing that and now he hosts of
terrible fucking song show where they have
to worse.
It's weird.
He's weird.
He's weird because I'm like,
this guy's a fucking rock star.
Like why are you not out?
Why are you doing what I do?
Dude,
you didn't my lowly hosting genre.
Is it your fucking like star?
He was sugar ran,
you know like God damn man.
Not that bad was bad ass that I just
want to fly song everyone loved song the
song of the summer.
That's a jam and song man.
Whenever and every time I hear that song,
I mean I don't know too
much of their other music,
but anytime I hear that song,
it was one big head.
I feel like just telling them,
listen,
if you can do that once for that song,
you can do more of that.
Please do more of that.
That song was awesome.
Why are you hosting these shows?
Man?
I sat a couple of hits,
right?
It's kind of being on the road.
We wouldn't all remember
the name Sugar Ray.
It was just one.
I don't know man.
I think for a lot of people,
sometimes it's just a different
opportunity to make money.
You don't have to rely on other people.
You might hear music anyway right now it
might be he doesn't want to rely on the
rest of the people in the band.
Sometimes his band,
she has can't keep it together.
You know,
they get,
I mean even Keith Richards and Mick Jagger
had ego problems like Keith Richards
just talk shit about
Mick Jagger in his book.
Like,
dude,
you guys have been boys or 70 years you
gotta Talk Shit and your book free son,
you know,
be honest.
Like screech.
That's what he said.
I heard.
Let's ruin it for gang bangs on fucking
sets all over the world screech ruined.
It was a big mouth.
Got To be honest about these gang bangs.
Now you know,
I know they're like Mario Lopez
can't get his freak on anymore.
You know,
let it do get his freak on screech.
Exactly.
Fucking weak ass bitch at sugar way.
I'd come into the comments
through a few times,
is he cool?
Cool.
I don't member sit there and laugh.
Doesn't call attention to himself.
He didn't really want
to fly the whole time.
I've heard him on stern before.
He's,
he's a cool dude for sure.
That's why I don't get it.
Like why are you doing what?
I could do
rock star family.
He might have a family.
It might be something like,
hey look,
I'd rather just fucking sure.
Yeah.
I think for a lot of people too,
like I said,
it's hard to work with a group of people.
Ho thing is really easy.
I came show to what's
are a couple in a day.
It's easy as fuck.
It's so easy.
It's stealing.
That's what I like.
Is this doing?
She does this show caught expose and
they play two a day and it's like I
recorded on my DVR and there's
like 30 we've got to get her back.
Was getting accused of not having girls.
I just saw her the other day.
Roy Destroys hilarious retards
cause it's the same day by the way.
Don't you do it again?
I was at Walmart and Walmart has this
tee shirt sections where it's like the
cool kid tee shirts.
Like it's Elmo.
It's like angry birds.
It's like for people like,
you know people who buy,
right?
Walmart,
Walmart.
So this is really weird
that they do ronic right?
Yeah.
They have Special Olympics
shirts now in the middle.
And I almost bought one.
But I was like,
that's rude because I would
be wearing that as a joke.
And I'm like,
wait a second,
this is in Walmart.
Wait a second.
This is supposed to boast.
That's fucked up.
Whoa.
So yeah,
go to your Walmart and buy them quick.
Take photos of it.
Someone's going to find out about that.
And this could get ugly.
I bought to,
I'm leaving as soon as
we get off the air here.
I know I'm running to
Walmart before they pull it.
I need to get that just to bring it.
I want,
I need to wear it on the show.
We need to all wear it next show.
All right,
we're gonna,
we're gonna take them off.
Send a picture at Walmart.
How dare you?
I'm saying it right now.
No.
How dare you fucking Weirdos okay with it.
Yeah.
I think it's funny.
You know,
it used to be okay to say retard.
I'm a little upset that you can't
say retarded anymore and you know,
and without people thinking that
you're brutally insensitive when,
what do I mean?
Has Our society really truly evolved or
they're just these hot button words now
that people choose to act on.
Because when you know,
when you're calling someone a retard,
I'm not saying you have down syndrome.
I'm not saying you have a disease.
You have down syndrome.
I'm saying you're retarded.
You're,
you're,
you're fucking slow to retard.
It's to slow down.
You know what I heard recently what they
just changed in New York that stands
out to Starbucks,
they changed the gender biased
bathrooms to have male and female is um,
whenever the brood is rude to run,
whatever,
it's segregating,
not segregate,
whatever it's mean to transgender people.
Yeah.
Cause women are having male or bathrooms
or 50 times where it's thinking,
why don't I understand that we should
be able to all shit right next to each
other and you guys can lick girls seat.
Well there are dealers,
they're all single stalls anyway.
Just make them bathrooms.
Who Cares?
Hmm.
I think a lot of dirty
fucking men sitting there,
stinky fat asses their Harry acids down
on the seats that they're going to have.
We don't have the trust part.
A little petite shaved baton,
little pink and peach like
beautiful Starbucks keeps it clean.
You could get unlucky dude.
You could totally roll snake eyes and
walk into Starbucks to a fucking shit task
trophy,
a shit splatter catastrophe.
You know you're adding in coffee with,
you know people that are eating
like fucking cupcakes and shit.
That's just like lightening rods.
That's like,
so it's like lighting a fuse
inside your asshole have,
you know,
because one of them like Starbucks
where the toilets just like that floppy
handle or that
Starbucks.
Yeah,
it won't catch and you got to lift
the lid up if it's one of those,
those,
those are dangerous though
in public restaurants.
If I actually lift the lid off yourself
because then people do the upper decker
where they shit and in
the upper part of this
toilet tassels people,
I grew up with,
everybody in Boston save
it just for those moments.
It's not a fucking goof.
C'Mon man is listen,
when it's really cold,
you need some shit to do.
You get bored groups that he took it,
he took a shit in a coffee mug and put
it on top of the day on top of play.
What was it?
A gas thing,
I guess they should know and he just
sit across the street and look at people
all day long.
Just stare at them for attending.
Awesome.
You know why?
So I'm sweating.
Re is a nice guy and we like them.
And then it's also funny whenever
someone shits on something,
it's just funny.
I was fucking,
I was watching this occupy Wall Street
thing and this guy shitting on a police
car.
But the way he's doing
these like so you know.
Yeah cause it's like smearing
all over is all laid back.
I mean he's like squeezing his ass of
his police car and he shitting all over
himself and I'm like this is like
the worst way to do that ever.
No,
you just supposed to get on top.
When I read the shining
down on it and this was it,
I read the headline before
I clicked and I'm like,
I already pictured in my head,
oh he's probably shitting on the wad,
healed or squatting and I got a hood,
a Puma pose and then I saw
him leaning against it.
I'm like,
what fucking assholes using the car as
a Douchey Aa to world and all it like a
Shitty Douche.
It's all getting explode.
He's wiping his ass.
He Shit in his ass over the car.
I'll just have my girlfriend spit it out.
That guy must have stunk for a long time.
See,
that makes me nauseous.
The smell of other people's shit is
the only thing that gets me anymore.
Since my time on fear factor,
puke doesn't make me nauseous.
Like I could be in a nightclub and on.
I'll throw up right in front
of me and I don't even flinch.
You ate a bug the other day,
one of the like e entertainment people
or something like that and he wanted to
do,
I saw it.
I said,
dude,
this is just protein.
If we were living in,
you know,
10,000 years ago,
this would be something you would
be happy to eat this bar food.
Thinking about that video on your phone.
Really just thinking about it
and then we'll be on my phone.
We can't talk about it though.
Some day we will someday we will,
ladies and gentlemen,
but right now due to contractual
obligations that I have with fear factor,
we have to keep some shit on the
raps when that gets on the air.
Dude,
when there's,
there's a bunch of shit that we did the
season that was sold way more over the
top than anything we ever did before.
Hot.
It's going to vary.
We were just sitting there,
standing there,
shaking each other's heads like,
what the fuck are we doing?
And you should've seen sales phase.
I should sal Sal's comedy club.
And he just sat there
like he saw a calm goat.
Yeah.
Like a ghost man.
I'm sorry,
the bug was nothing.
It didn't taste bad at all.
What kind of bug was it?
Who was a,
um,
an African cave dwelling.
Spider.
It's terrifying.
There's ones with the
tons of crazy long lost.
Yeah.
It's basically a giant alive,
crabbing,
shortness.
Your first,
how big?
Well,
it's spread out.
It's about that big and
what you do smell it up.
Yeah,
I grabbed that bitch by the center
and just stuff it in there right away.
Just by the legs.
All smash that motherfucker quick.
I smashed them up quick.
But it's a lot of chewing,
you know.
But it didn't really taste that bad.
And,
um,
but you know,
I knew that you new it's been okay.
It's been okay.
This won't hurt me.
Yeah.
People have been eating
those things forever.
Humans have been eating bugs
forever to the tastes good.
And anyway,
no,
I appreciate that.
It's,
it's not bad.
I could look those giant
Madagascar hissing cockroaches.
I had one of those in the show too and uh,
there's a lot that's gross and eating
those things but it's also a good form of
protein.
If you're really starving to death,
you would totally eat that.
I think the grossest wants out
of this big green with a garden
tomato hornworms one of those too.
They just exploded,
just pouring out.
It was gross.
It was really hard to drink.
Really hard to do.
Like what,
what did that taste like?
Real bitter and it tasted like
you shouldn't be eating it like,
like nature's trying to warn you,
which I was assuming they are.
I mean I'm not,
I'm not into acquiring any
tastes if I don't like it.
Initially I don't like it.
You know,
like the idea,
like caviar was always a weird one to me.
Like it's an acquired taste.
Do you like it?
Oh,
it's a choir.
Like what does that mean?
You're going to spend like 5,000
bucks for something that's acquired.
It's more expensive,
but I'm getting into this
to enjoy some stupid eggs,
but some weird ritualistic thing almost.
It's like,
you know,
you're,
you're getting eggs of this
animal that's very rare.
Look,
you get to crush it's babies before
they ever it on your cracker.
Fishing with David Taylor
in Alaska and we cut up one of the
fishes and all these things in there and
David took,
what's this?
And the guy's like eggs and he's like,
is that caviar?
Can I eat it?
And this guy was like,
you.
I mean,
if you want David,
just start eating more and more of it.
Every time we call it pregnant salmon,
he would just eat more and
more of it until the veteran.
He was like,
oh,
I have to fill up now.
He was so nauseous from
eating all that sand.
You're not supposed to
eat fucking a pound of,
of warm salmon eggs.
Not,
I don't think so.
It happens.
You barred from actually on the open sea.
Wow.
They'd be grilled on the beat on the,
on the boat.
It was so funny.
It look good food.
What does he think?
He was just eating it
because it was caviar.
Not that it was good or,
yeah,
he was like,
oh,
it's free.
I should get this as
much as I can right now.
Fresh,
fresh.
Is He German?
That guy is comes from German
descent or English I think.
I think there's an issue with salmon.
You have to be careful with salmon.
You're not even really
supposed to eat Sushi.
If you talk to some quote unquote experts.
Yeah,
that's fresh water.
Especially salmon because
salmon is its potential.
It has a potential for parasites.
It's not likely,
but it's got a potential.
You don't know.
You know most of the farm raised stuff,
you know,
I just,
I have it on the head with farm raised.
Those are,
they taste better man.
It's wild.
You know when you,
this is where it weirds me out.
Farm raised is like pink and you know
when they put it in a store they die.
That shit like diet,
pay,
die,
make it look like a healthy wild salmon.
But it literally becomes such a bit.
And the only way I know again
gets like it loses its soul.
Yeah.
And that crazy,
the color drops out and it tastes worse.
Yeah.
It tastes worse.
What's not worthy?
It's not as worthy to catch that goes
along with my theory that things that can
get away real quick or better for you.
So I fishes so good for you.
So fucking hard to catch.
You know dear dear is great for you.
So hard to catch the
[inaudible] or the other,
they're so quick.
They have what they have is so good.
It's easy to catch you.
They run away real fast.
It's so good that they develop nature
gave them a chance and that chance as you
get to be faster than the
people so that they can't,
you know,
just being able to be out and not being
depressed cause cause cause I'm a farm
raised cows tastes better
than grain fed cows,
right?
Yes they do.
Well it's a different taste.
They can sort of be out.
Yeah.
I buy a grass fed beef whenever I can.
And uh,
it's a different taste.
It's like a game animal almost.
It's really weird.
I'm kind of exaggerating,
but it's a,
it's different.
It's way,
way,
way leaner.
So you have to be real
careful when you cook it.
You can't cook it for very long,
you know,
really an overcook it big on,
really dry on the grass fed.
It's delicious.
Well,
he's a crossfit fanatic Eddie,
if to our buddies,
like in crazy shape or I
suppose he's always like,
try to get me to squeeze
your shoulders and shit.
Fucking crossfit.
I'm talking about his dead lifts
and feel my fucking shoulders.
When those people do that at the same,
it's pretty much you're telling me
about your fantasy football team.
Well,
you know,
no,
I totally
see what is coming from me.
People think that it's kind of,
um,
you know,
it's kind of,
there's kind of a gross thing
about worrying about what
your body looks like and
being really into your body.
There's something gross about it,
you know?
And yeah,
it is a little vague,
but that said,
isn't it more fun to have like
what's essentially a super body?
Isn't it more fun to have a body that
can do all kinds of crazy shit that
already regular body can't do.
So when you know,
Eddie's in there dead lifting and shit
and I'm putting these big lifts in and
doing these crazy kettlebell
workouts and shit,
you just start feeling like,
wow,
I feel fucking vibrant.
You know,
my body feels good like this.
I love the fact that he
can go in there and have a,
a ferocious workout and
feel fantastic afterwards,
you know,
so it's just,
it,
uh,
it just gets a little work.
It is a lot of laughter.
A lot of,
I wish I could just get that
they just opened this gym
gym up that been going to,
or a once in a while curves,
curves for women and they let me go in
there if I talk it and now it's right
next to,
uh,
this race or this fast food place I go to.
And,
uh,
all the beefy guys come in there.
And what's so weird is this one guy came
in there and he looked like you looked
at him and you're like,
that is amazing.
Like his,
his,
his structure.
He looks like a real GI Joe Guy.
Like that looks like a Gi Joe Guy.
And then he got his food and he was like
getting Sawso from the salsa bar and he
was putting in his bag and
he folded like the bag down.
So like anger or not angry
like it had be folded,
like all the lines had to be like all
the lines had to be straight and stuff
like that.
And then this guy goes,
oh here's one more,
something like that.
And he just got this mad look
like he was like unfolding it,
having to put it in there.
And it was like,
we are both looking at it going,
wow,
that guy's going to emerge.
Yeah.
My friend was PSI in college.
This Ethiopian guy used to work out
and at the top of his lifts we go,
I'm going to fuck somebody up.
Like getting into bar fights.
I love doing it.
That's what kept them going.
Did you see that light getting in the bus?
So he would pick fights with people?
It starts at not hard and be like,
you would have to fight back.
But
have you talked about
the steroids documentary?
Bigger,
stronger,
faster.
Smilier I haven't seen it,
so no.
You know,
I never watched,
so I watched like little clips of it.
I actually own it on DVD,
but it never bothered watching it.
It's not bad.
It's,
it's pretty interesting.
It,
it would,
I didn't know though is like,
well also they should,
there's cows on there.
This steroid cows.
Well they are,
yeah.
It's not really a steroid.
Now there's this thing that
happens to certain cows where the,
uh,
it's a myostatin inhibitor and it
goes wrong and when it goes wrong,
they grow like three times.
The regular [inaudible] muscle dude,
the dog's Huston.
No,
it's just from,
from breeding there's somehow
or another their genetics,
you know,
I've seen those,
those gigantic house like three
times the size of a person.
And we were seeing the dogs too.
There's a whippet it happens too,
but specifically to whip.
It's for some reason
whippets are very slight dog,
very fast.
It's fairly big,
but I mean it's not a tiny done but tall,
but it's,
yeah,
it's a thin dog.
But these whippets that have
this myostatin inhibitor issue.
Fucking swole.
Like captain America,
like the Hulk,
like ridiculous.
Like you would swear.
It's photo-shopped.
There's photos of 'em online.
I'll find one for you just
because you need to peek at it.
And it's just the weirdest fucking thing.
How do you spell whippets?
The way I used to do them,
they were WBA
PP maybe.
Yeah,
maybe.
Do you have a really good cracker?
Did you always buy like
a cheap plastic one?
Whatever it gonna be,
Simon.
I got like this nice
chrome one from wireless.
Yeah.
They used to sell them on how to
take a look at this real quick.
You just have to see this because
it doesn't even seem real.
Look in his eyes doesn't,
oh,
that looks like a famous actor.
Credible.
Is that incredible for folks?
For folks who don't know what this is,
just look up weapons.
Wipp I think it's p,
p,
t,
s,
whatever it was,
what?
Look up whip.
It's,
you'll find it.
It'll,
it's,
it's dummy proof the Internet these days.
It'll offer you suggestions,
but weapons on steroids.
If you look at it,
you'll find this,
this poor dog with this,
uh,
this defect that comes from just a part.
It's just as for some reason it
happens more commonly with weapons.
I read it explained,
but I don't remember the explanation.
But essentially this myostatin inhibitor
issue just gives them this incredible
amount of muscle.
Like the dog looks like
something out of a cartoon.
It looks like something out of.
Um,
did you see the Hawk not,
never saw him to fucking one with Eric
Bana was the shit with Nick naulty and
uh,
the dogs,
they had these,
these crazy dogs that were infected,
but the hulk,
Sam know dogs are turned to help dogs.
Oh No.
When they got mad,
yeah,
the dogs would get mad.
Who'd come hope dogs and they were fucking
ridiculously awesome and hot dogs in
the hallway.
He got in a fight.
Oh,
okay.
They were going to walk up and epic.
Dude,
it was awesome.
But now went back moment in three d
special effects really when they were
regular dogs with a cool,
fun.
No,
they knew what was up for the bad guy,
bro.
They were working for the bad guy,
let it rolled.
He jacked him with the hulk
serum and fucking and say,
that's not real.
If it was you could jack with a hotel.
They would just be mayhem.
It wouldn't know how to attack for you
unless you were trained killer dogs
already.
But why would the dog listened
to you once it becomes,
yeah,
it would just do whatever it wants
to come and listen and you stupid.
We just do mayhem.
Oh No.
Oh
yeah.
He would just bark and you would go
flying across the room just from the,
the bark,
like the transformers would do that.
The evil transport.
What to do that just to create Alex,
but I know two dogs,
they try so hard with
the hulk movie.
Did they just Redo it
with different people?
Hey,
the Hawk is for sale right now,
by the way.
Yeah.
And they,
they're selling all these like real props,
like the iron man,
like best and stuff like that.
And one of the things with the whole head,
I tap out way before we really,
I'm not that Geeky.
Yeah.
But they were like
saying the price is like,
it's so far it price had
been around in the thousands,
like one thousand two thousand dollars.
I'm like,
wow.
Can you imagine coming in and go into
your living room having this glass case
with the Hawk hedge is
sitting there going,
I have any bad,
I would be pretty bad ass.
The original holds.
What's his name?
Uh,
I think it was from the first frig.
No,
there's this from that one.
no,
I think it's from the first movie.
It is a thing.
Is it something there's
no,
it's,
I dunno.
I'll show you what,
I'll try it.
Pro Lou Ferrigno was
told me to stop smoking.
He told you?
Yeah.
I took,
I took an acting class with his wife once
a long time ago and we're all standing
outside of that was waiting
around during a break or for them,
you know,
so we were all smoking and he was
sitting in the car waiting for,
took to come out.
He's like,
you shouldn't smoke.
Whoa.
And I was like,
yeah,
I know.
It's,
it's prepared for me.
I know.
And then when I turned
back around and my friend,
and then I turned back around to see him
after like a minute and he's still just
staring at me and he goes,
uh,
surgery shouldn't smoke.
And I was like,
yes,
sir.
Put it out.
No,
he just said it well,
more forceful.
Wow.
Said it more serious.
And I was like,
I'm not taking a chance.
It's because so big.
He's Lou Ferrigno.
Yeah.
He was on the mantra
when I was hosting it,
really?
And,
uh,
I met him and I said,
hey Lou,
I'm Joe.
Thank you very much.
It's really an honor to meet shows or
always a huge friend ever since back in
the pumping iron days.
And it's not.
That goes all.
Thanks.
Some really excited.
Do you work out to you?
That's what you said.
You work out.
I'm like son
do.
I worked at a fucking kid that was
born with this motherfucker right here.
Come on kid.
What if you were born of my that
you'd have such a horrible life.
Ridiculous.
Just giant.
Make us in your arms and kids
that you see once in a while.
That's ship photos.
Really muscular kids.
It was just so surreal
talking to Lou Ferrigno.
You and I are talking about working out.
What do you want to talk to him?
A lot of kettlebells like to did you just
dude makes fun of the man.
You so rig.
No,
Brian make it fun.
I love the Frig.
No,
one day
she had to take it to the
lowest common denominator.
All right.
You went for the low hanging fruit.
He didn't know what anywhere around
these just trying to be on him side.
These hopes don't talk man.
That whole time actually just this was a
hawk standing so like cause it was CGI.
I think it's what they used for people
who are looking at cameras and stuff like
that.
Let me see what it looks.
It does look good.
It looks pretty creepy.
You're not buying that thing.
Don't buy that.
What are you talking about?
All right.
What do you my dad buy it
now and it's on a stick to,
it's on TMC
son.
No,
I'm probably not going to
Marvel's having this pretty dope.
It's pretty dope.
I'll tell you what I would buy.
I would buy the,
the head of the American
Werewolf in London.
The original best werewolf of all time.
Yeah.
There's been a few werewolf movies that
have been kind of fun over the years,
but none can fuck with an
American Werewolf in London.
That movie,
it looks so real.
It looks so real.
That movie,
and it was a long ass time ago,
dude,
they did that shit in the
80s I movie rocks so much.
It looks so much better than
that fixed star wars stuff.
When that thing was in London,
when it was fucking people up in
the streets when it came out of the,
the dirty movie theater.
It kills everybody in the dirty movie
theater on the London streets like they
showed just enough of it
to scare the fuck out.
They didn't have to close up,
show the thing moving around
because when you do that,
then people get used to it and
they knew how to do it back then.
You know those,
those,
the special effects were not nearly as if,
as Lou Joe's scared me so bad that
I walked 45 minutes out of my way,
wants to get back home after saying
it instead of the seven minutes,
it would have taken a fine.
That's scary.
They knew how to,
I mean the American Werewolf in London,
people,
I guess it's John Landis and whoever
else was involved in John to that.
Yeah.
Whoever else was involved in
creating the imagery behind it.
Just such an awesome job.
A special effects guy was
supposed to be some legendary.
How the vice guy,
oh,
it's Rick Baker.
He's the man,
but he's also the guy who did the last
wolf man with Benicio Del Toro and I
didn't like that special effects at all.
I thought that was a silly choice.
They went,
they went with this loan,
Chaney junior look from like or whoever
the fuck you original wolf man was as a
long Chaney Jr uh,
I was original wolf man.
Don Not Vamos Paul.
Oh,
Claude rains.
Well it says Claude
rains and loan Chaney Jr.
I'm not sure which one was the uh,
the monster.
I think it's long.
Chaney Junior.
And they went to look like,
yeah.
Yeah.
My point is that movie is from 1941,
man.
And so what they did is like
an updated version of it.
It looked real.
It looked like a thing that's
just a stylistic choice.
But as long as it looks
real as that version of it,
well their idea was they wanted to be
a real person instead of a CGI thing
because they had this great actor.
And when do you get an actor
as good as Benito del Tora Way,
man.
So use him to embody the beast
and then you'll do some CGI,
like his legs were Cgi,
so they bet backwards like a
dog's legs and shit like that,
which is really weird that
he's walking upright on those.
But it's a movie,
but the,
the real issue is the exact opposite of
what you got from the American wealth in
London for the American
Werewolf in London,
there was mystery.
There was like,
there's a scene where this guy
gets killed in the London subway,
there's shithead and
he's kind of a shithead.
So you kind of like a happy with you guys.
Yeah,
he's a dickhead and he's just stumbling.
Fuck.
And he's trying to hold
onto his briefcase.
And so this thing is,
he's running and this thing's chasing
how many falls down on an escalator.
And as he's going on this escalator up,
you see the thing at the bottom of
the escalator and that ends the scene.
And it's terrifying.
You just know what's terrifying.
You don't have to see a killer.
Yeah.
It's terrifying because they just played
at just enough where you don't even get
to see it.
He sees it and you can see it in his
eyes and he runs and then you hear the
thing in the background making this crazy
noise and he's running and you can't
see it.
And then finally in the end of the scene,
you see it at the bottom of the
stairs and that's all you need,
man.
That's all you need.
They show that movie is the absolute
perfect Horror Monster Werewolf movie to
watch that again now,
so the best and it's got some humor in it.
There's something I want to see in there.
He gets laid Shizam it's everything.
You want to have a movie
that one hot English bitches.
Holla at your boy.
That's what
I forgot what I was just,
sorry.
I don't know,
but if I had a head,
that's what I would buy.
I wouldn't buy the whole kit,
but I'll by the American
Werewolf in London,
I would buy robocop probably
or something like that.
From your childhood.
You remember it or star wars.
Star Wars did this,
this desk.
It's so fucking weird.
That's sort of where it's so much.
You're such a like,
it's just a mixture of the
weirdest shit I've ever seen.
Stevia and marijuana and knives.
Dog Tag,
weird reading glasses,
tablets and the skulls.
It's my mind.
Skull fucking belt buckle.
Stanley Kubrick's Odyssey.
The hidden.
It looks like what's buried with a mummy.
What the fuck?
This is just like a god.
If they unbury the uncovered
this 2000 years from now,
I'd be like,
what was this?
This was like an error made and
they came in here and we're like,
wow,
these treasures,
these must be treasuries.
This is all a mixture of my message.
Must have been a collector pile all
this together and this is my message.
Well you know if they like
you look around my house,
I collect like a lot of weird shit.
I can see you buying that giant hood,
putting it somewhere.
I probably would if you,
if you weren't here and if
you didn't make fun of it,
but it saved me,
saved me from a ridiculous purchase.
Ebay does get me,
it's like five grand to somebody who's
going to make a purchase on something.
Probably it said two grand.
Now if it's on Ebay grant already,
it'll probably jack up the,
the last day they say on Ebay is where
it really all goes going to go in five
seconds.
Really.
They have these things
where like Ebay sniping,
I think it's what it's called,
where it's like people that,
I think there are programs
that automatically sit
there and at the last second
just throw in like real fast math,
math to like try to beat it real quick.
Wow Dude.
That kind of stuff kind of freaks me out.
Like little little bots and little things
and people are incorporated on the web
so you can
automatically bid at the last second we
anything like that or people automate
things.
It's like when you open up the
door for hoax stirs and Tunis and,
and coders and people know how
to tweak things and you know,
it's like,
remember when you used to play online?
If here just play quake online
and people would get bought,
drink,
drank,
you know what a bot is and it's bullshit.
Or a Bot is like sort of your plot.
Here's what it is.
There's artificial intelligence involved
in quake and they figured out a way to,
when they make the game,
it's a d first person shooters.
So you're running through all these crazy
corridors and you see other characters
in there and you shoot at each other,
right?
You know,
you're looking at it through
your own perspective.
And when,
when,
when they make these,
uh,
these,
these video games,
you can have one of these artificial
intelligence people and just insert them
into the game and yeah.
Well,
you can also have,
you could have it set
up so you never miss.
You can have a Bot that just knows,
see it read the code.
Of course.
Nice cheating.
He reads the code and it knows absolutely
exactly where your character is at all
times.
So every time you press the launch button,
you cannot miss,
right?
So you're just killing
people in like three seconds.
As soon as you see them,
and I've played with people
like this online and it's like,
it's really frustrating.
It's like you're not
playing a real person.
You play and they're
laughing and I'm like,
I'm doing it.
Like,
do what?
This is stupid.
Obviously we're going
to beat me like this.
Yeah.
I don't know what my point was.
I had a point.
Oh,
what do you think of these bots that
automatically bid that kind of shit?
Did it ruin quake?
Never draw that back to
they're really nice dude.
Strong memory that,
yeah.
There was a very circuitous route
and just took in this conversation.
Yeah,
exactly.
My friend who asked me,
I'm in college,
it was early on,
but he gets automated telling me to keep
calling your phone over and over again,
my dorm phone.
So we just fill up my voice mail.
Why would he do that?
Just to be a dick.
And that's when you
give people that power.
It's like,
all right.
It was funny once,
don't keep doing it for a fucking month.
You have to trust shitty pranksters
when you have comics for friends,
man.
They're always,
it's like,
all right,
I got it.
It was good.
And leave it alone as code
of ethics about your praying,
trying to fuck with people.
I've got some excellent Photoshop,
Brendan Walsh,
uh,
putting a girl's chaps on in Houston.
I'm not sure he wants that shit
on you to give the girls chaps.
Yeah.
But Holla at him.
Uh,
Brendan,
B r e n d o n Walsh on Twitter.
And contact him and tell him,
Yo,
it's at least released the info.
Dude.
It's hilarious.
He's in his underwear in
a country western bar.
It takes his pants off.
Really?
He's trying to put on the waitresses
chaps and I got video of him.
I'm interviewing him while this
is going down and he's Pi Pi side.
He's going to be in a
Ontario this weekend,
right?
Yes.
Yeah.
He's going to be in the Ontario
this weekend with Joey and me.
Where are you at are this weekend?
This weekend?
I'm here.
You're here.
You're in Hollywood.
You're doing the storytelling
shows on next Thursday.
Actually storytellers show next Thursday.
The improv.
Yeah.
What?
What is that?
That date?
20th powerful.
I'm in town.
I'll be there to lend support.
What's the subject?
Um,
Halloween stuff.
I got no stories through song.
You write your own pitch as have fun live.
I lived in a haunted
house for a little bit.
Really has a dare to win.
Some will know it because I really believe
if you really believe in that Shit,
which I pretty much don't
to the haunted houses.
No,
not really.
I don't really.
Um,
my,
uh,
my grandmother was supposedly psychic,
not on one.
I'm good.
Thanks.
My grandmother was supposedly psychic.
She was a very,
very strange lady.
And,
um,
she,
she did know things.
She had this weird way of like,
she would tell you,
like she told my father
just had a nowhere,
or my grandfather,
I should told them out of nowhere,
Chow call your mother,
call your mother right now.
And he was,
he was like doing some crossword puzzle.
They were always like,
this is how they would talk to each other.
She would yell at him and he would go,
I write,
I write.
Yeah.
He,
uh,
he goes to visit his mom and
as he gets to his mom's house,
as she dies,
he,
he is there the moment she dies,
as he walks in the door,
he gets to see her last seconds of life
and she says goodbye to him and then she
dies.
Wow.
And somehow or another,
my grandmother knew this and uh,
it could have been just a crazy lucky gas.
It could have been total bullshit.
She wanted him out of the
house and she just got lucky,
know difficult.
Who knows?
But also scientifically it could be.
Yeah.
I think she died the next day.
She did weird shit.
The story over the years,
she would do weird shit.
Like one time,
um,
she woke my mother up out of her bed
and brought her downstairs and then five
minutes later the roof collapsed
over her bed and fucked her bat up.
Yeah,
there was weird shit like that.
Anyway,
they had a guy,
this is back in,
then my grandparents lived in Newark,
New Jersey.
And uh,
it was,
uh,
it started out in all Italian neighborhood
and then it became an all black
neighborhood.
Then it became an all Puerto Rican
neighborhood and Dominican's and all these
other people moved in.
And my grandparents,
they stayed there forever.
And at one point in time,
uh,
they,
they were renting the room out apparently
to some dude and dude died and they
swore that this dude
was still in the house.
It goes,
you know,
and that was like where I was staying.
I was staying in that same room.
Did you ever see anything?
I didn't say shit.
I didn't see shit.
I walked around on my
deck and my hand like,
what?
I'm not scared of ghosts.
Come blow me then grove his son right now.
What are you,
you gonna scare me?
Woo.
Woo little.
You're not even there.
You're translucent,
Bro.
Like go right through.
You stupid.
Stop Bothering Kale,
Huh?
No,
they don't do shit.
You have to be a total pussy
to be scared of a ghost.
Those fucking ghost shows
to drive me bananas.
I never find anything.
There's nothing there.
You Fox and explained
this Geiger readings,
they have a fucking leg.
They have a like a circle that
they'll highlight on a screen.
Look at this moment,
there's something appears
for kind of dresser.
There's nothing behind that dress.
You asshole.
It's lit in your screen.
Are you talking about a camera from 1978
where we are down in the basement in
the readings are off the chart.
This is amazing.
And they're all,
it's all night vision
and you see the knife?
I don't hear that.
Do you hear that?
I don't hear it there.
One of the first
when the first threads I ever
did on your message board ways.
I,
my sister,
I think it was,
she went to this haunted house,
a famous haunted house in West
Virginia and they stayed at,
and she took a photo using our camera
and one of the first things I ever posted
on your form was like these photos
because it actually had like a person that
looked like a ghost standing on the
porch and it was fucking creepy.
And I've been trying to find that,
that photo for so many years.
I lost it.
It's not in your archive thing anymore,
but it's like the photos are goes now too.
Well,
what do you think goes?
What'd he say?
I can't believe nobody
even asked you this,
but do you know the orbs thing?
You know about orbs?
Yeah.
No.
Okay.
This is where it gets hilarious.
There's a apparently hold on,
hold on,
hold on.
Before you start those.
Okay.
I just want to say whenever
I hear stories like this,
I know in my brain I can call it.
I always like,
all right,
what's the story going to be about and
if these whatever these things are orbs
or we're so awesome.
Why am I just hearing about it now?
Because you know what it is.
You probably know it by something,
some other name.
You know what I mean?
Like whenever it's,
I'd be story like that or like,
you know,
going into the light
when you die or whatever.
I want to hear it.
Well it's a,
it's a photographic artifact.
Oh,
from mostly from digital photography.
Okay.
What it is,
it shows these little circular things
that look like it's probably dust in the
air and cashes the,
the flash that creates like little orbs,
orbs.
But people are convinced that
it's like positive spirits.
Oh there are beings and that the dust
just like positive spirits and like the
more dust I guess you collect around you,
there's holes are like little fairies.
So what?
They're hoarders or like well they
believe what they believe is some people
believe that when you have
like all this positive energy,
that positive energy actually manifests
itself in these fears but that you
cannot see it.
They're gonna only be viewed
when it's photograph question.
How did I know that there are
positive fares and not negative?
I don't know.
Cause they say if you talk to the people
who really believe in it and Bravo they
say that it when it shows up,
when you have positive
thoughts and positive energy
and I've seen some pictures,
I've received your really interesting
pictures of like people happy smiling and
they're holding their hands up
and there's orbs all around,
all of their photo but
it also could be lent.
Has it ever been a picture
of somebody's happy it does
and dust and stuff.
But there,
there is definitely a lot of weird shit
that happens in photos that aren't,
that isn't dust.
But the problem is is that thinks
anything,
it means it's a ghost.
It's got to be out.
Speaking of which,
have you guys heard about this new
Photoshop thing that removes the Biller?
How's that takes up?
If you take a photo saying it
feels it's like a blurry photo,
it can calculate where each image went
wrong and how it all stretched out and
they could turn it into an unbeliever.
He picture would,
it pretty much looks,
it looks at the photo and does its math,
like how the blur is and it finds the
path that like if you're holding the
camera and you first
what it would have been.
Yeah,
like if you're holding the camera,
you're taking a photo and it
goes a little right there.
It can see that in the camera by the blur.
The blur is and so it tries to reverse
that and straighten it back together and
it works really well.
If one of my favorite things on the iPhone
is when you open up a picture and it
opens up,
but it's this blurry for
a second and you're like,
oh,
I can already see it.
Let's see it better and it gets all clear.
I love it.
I love that feeling.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
You guys should definitely
upgrade to the cloud thing.
It's nice.
I can now look at every photo like
on my home computer right now.
And you know those dreams,
everything from your
home computer constantly,
constantly.
Does that mean if you lose your phone,
someone's going to see
all your Dick Pictures?
Uh,
final?
No,
no.
Cause you have brass farms,
you have a password lock on it.
By the way,
I just found out about this program.
I don't,
I can't find it yet and I
can't remember the name.
But there's this program that you could
put on your iPhone that if somebody gets
the pass code wrong,
it will automatically take a photo of the,
of the using the front camera.
And so then if you lose
it then you can track it.
Also using Google maps,
you can play alarms that you can
have a recorded from your computer.
I know you've got my phone.
Yeah,
I can't remember the name of it.
So from your computer at home,
but you control it from a mobile
money account or whatever it is.
Yeah.
So it's in the iCloud.
Wow.
Yeah.
I can't remember the name though.
Fuck.
Well,
it's like sling shot or somebody
tweaked that shit to us please.
I know you are.
You're out there.
You Oh witters or hoarders
of information that,
that thing that I had,
that video they had on the,
on the,
um,
the voice control was incredible.
We were military Steve Jobs.
You know what bugs me about it is that
now people are going to be using that
shit all day and telling him just having
fucking conversations with their phone.
There's going to be all these
robots talking everywhere.
You know,
like you're going to be in a coliseum
and you're just gonna hear like tons of
robots.
What's playing at the movies
that's going to happen.
They're just going to wander
around and talking to their call.
Margaret,
I can't wait to us higher ratings.
I heard,
fuck,
I could hurt.
You could fuck with it and like
ask it crazy questions like,
who made you,
are you?
Would you marry me?
And she's,
that's where it'd be like,
yeah.
Okay.
Apple.
If apple let people have like,
you know,
like do shit to it.
Like you could do to like Unix
or Linux or something like that
because then you could
make like fuck mods.
Right?
You could have some dirty bitch
that gives you your text messages.
I can go and dirty bitch,
you know?
Tell me,
tell me what the fuck,
what,
what kind of texts I got.
Oh,
this is what I got first.
I got a message from a sucky did
real good since that's the baby.
Yeah.
How's my tax looking?
I would make an Ari Shaffir said and
then she reads a text message so you can
say like dirty shit to you.
They call you dirty boy.
You want your message from Ari.
You can have why got don't you little
bitch thousands and thousands of
programmed responses to various questions
that possibly could come up and you
can just talk dirty to this bitch.
They should have an avid program.
They should have an APP or a girl.
You can keep track of the cycle and the
way it'll show you where you are in a
cycle is how much a guy can get
away with not using a condom.
Really.
So when she's closer to obviating,
maybe like three condoms owners on
the picture they've gun or something.
And then when they,
she's like,
whenever the time is when
you just totally not fertile,
just so blessed away.
Condoms are the grossest
things of all time.
I really even,
you know,
they're necessary,
don't get me wrong,
but it Christ stupid fucking rubber
sword over your dick feel like ridiculous
nonsense.
We're so gross though.
We so gross.
We give each other Kudos
through our dicks pussies.
I mean,
it's not just an issue of Islam
is an issue of making people,
which is most certainly a fucking issue
because there's a lot of people you
fucked that you don't
want to make people with.
That's a dirty God damn trick of
nature that we need to fix pronto.
You know?
Instead of trying to
fucking get rid of the Fed,
listen and let's try to fix that.
Let's try to fix this fucking equals
making people thing about that equals man,
fuck for fun.
And then if you want to make people,
you know you have to be
able to turn something off.
It should be a better person.
I was really considering it
a sec to me the other day,
which is like 10 minutes
of serious thought into it.
You're crazy.
You don't want kids if
you don't want kids.
No.
One of the worst things that could happen
to me right now cause I get someone
pregnant.
Well,
so why would it be crazy?
Like cheaper to own a gun.
Have you been Joe?
Have you say that?
But you know what man,
it sounds crazy,
but if you haven't checked that you were
really into and you had a little ori
hanging around you,
you would love a fucking love it.
You would love it in a way that
I couldn't even describe to you.
It just seems like a huge
commitment and a huge time eater.
It's just got to meet the right guy.
And what if it was,
what if it was to girl?
That's not the issue going and it's
not cool enough to get rid of it.
I have several friends that have
children with people they don't like.
I know a bunch of people in that
situation and it's a sad situation.
That's what I mean.
That's the worst thing that
could happen to me right now.
Yeah.
But it doesn't mean that you're,
I wish there was a reversible way
cause that's the only negative is okay.
At some point I want to do this,
but somebody who I believe there is,
I believe there's new
technology that they uh,
they attach a clip and it
basically pinches off your,
where your dick sauce comes out like over
a Doritos bag and I don't know how it
works,
but your body just sort of reabsorbs it.
So
your,
your loads are all,
it's just blanks,
a gigantic thing of sperm.
The next time when you
open up the flood gates,
it must be one super,
super.
Yeah.
Dead,
uh,
pushing forth fucking armies
and John laying carpet,
new carpet.
That's what sound,
that's it.
Your loads and felt like I felt like a
week or two they'll have that smell when
you first go into a apartment when
they've just done it on you and laying the
carpet down.
I like smells,
smells like it should.
It's the most clean.
Such a crap shoot apartment living.
It's always a crap shoot.
We always had weird neighbors,
man.
Have you ever had an apartment?
We had cool neighbors.
Like every now and then you hear about
somebody who's got some set up somewhere
and there's like a cool
apartment building and every,
you know,
it's small place and yeah.
And everybody's cool.
I'm only friends with
my next door neighbors.
They before they both
work at the store nearby.
Me Too.
Oh,
they both work at the store?
Yeah.
And so it's like,
I know,
but that's crazy.
You look outside with one
of them sometimes with like,
so you got three people from the
comedy store and one little one.
They work at the um,
none of them.
Oh,
the corner store.
Is that what you're saying?
Here are the one right below it.
Yeah.
Not The comedy store.
No,
you got a nice convenience setup.
But that store right there too.
It was at store 24 hours.
No,
two of them to those bitches.
Yeah.
Weak ass bitch.
Sometimes I've been up to,
we're at a point like one
time they open please six.
That was sex.
There used to be one point in time,
a 24 hour pool.
All Hollywood billiards.
There's 24 hour pool hall
in La and it was awesome.
I came here before the earthquake,
the first team to know
what happened there.
Yeah,
yeah.
But no,
they moved,
they moved from their location.
That wasn't the original location.
Now their religion
location was downstairs.
I forget what street it was on,
but it was an awesome old CD place.
And uh,
I came down here to do some shit for MTV.
Me and I did this little thing,
this little rock and spring.
Breck,
no,
I was like,
oh,
Highlet thing we did.
It was me and a couple of different people
tried it with me and they just had me
out here for a few days.
But one of the highlights of my trip
was I got that go to that Hollywood
billiards before it went under.
It was just bad ass man.
I went downstairs,
I was like,
oh,
sign me up.
This place is perfect.
I know.
I saw people arguing over how much to bat.
I saw,
I saw people playing money playing pool
for money and it was like two o'clock in
the morning and I saw some posers.
I saw some like,
you know some when I don't
want to say pollsters,
people didn't really know how to
play pool that well I should say.
And then I'm not posers people
just banging balls around.
So there was like regular
people and there was like,
you know,
there was that actor from um,
fuck,
what movie was he in?
16 candles.
Was that the,
the dude he,
Michael Thomas.
What does it say?
What does Michael Michael Hall,
yeah,
it's hacking people.
That Guy Michael,
I saw him there.
I also saw him at domino,
Hollywood,
Hollywood athletic club.
That was another place
where they used to have a,
that was an awesome little
pool hall that closed down.
These failed to play pool with
a bunch of different places.
I like a stupid sport.
It's dying.
It's dying right in front of mine,
but I won't accept it.
Too much space.
It's too fun.
It's too fun to play.
Won't accept.
I want to it.
They're crazy.
Fuck you fucking mother.
It's not mine.
It's mine.
It's my home phone.
Doesn't do the cool party anymore.
Now I don't even care about anymore.
Yeah,
that's even better.
You're going to have it ring man.
At least have a robot voice.
Fram Jelly
name man.
Damn man.
Learn.
You want to call it from whoever.
That was an important character.
Really?
Yeah.
It was supposed to.
I forgot to tell him I couldn't do this.
I have to do a podcast.
I had to talk to him real quick resident.
Was it the president?
Was that Obama?
Have you been following the latest news
now on what a bond is killing us all at
the raping her children.
Medical Marijuana.
It's so pathetic there.
They're going after medical marijuana
like on an aggressive way and not,
hold on,
hold on.
Okay.
Yeah.
Well,
I just want to know if this is the
attorney general or if it's Obama or the
state's attorneys,
like a bodiless day.
Okay,
go for it changed its stance and the
stance was originally that they would only
go after people who violated
both state and federal law.
What's that?
Your phone is off.
The phone's off the hook.
Yeah.
But the problem with state
and federal law is the state,
the state law.
I've,
I've seen parts of it.
It says you can't operate for profit,
which everyone sort of does and it's
just sort of like what's for profit,
what's not and that I don't
think you're allowed to profit,
but you're definitely allowed to make
money too to actually pay for employees I
think and things like that.
So I think if you do do it by the book
and not like some of these places,
that's also selling cocaine gets
all their money to the employees.
They take some for themselves.
That's how,
that's why you run a business.
I wish I believed them.
I wish.
I believe that when they were really
doing was eradicating the evil people who
were a part of this peaceful
medical and medical marijuana scene,
peaceful and helpful medical marijuana
scene and what we're going to do is just
eradicate the the ones that are problems.
Right.
But if you really were
caring about people,
that's not what you would
concentrate on first.
Okay.
You wouldn't concentrate on people
distributing marijuana even if they were
doing it illegally.
What are they doing?
They're getting good stuff out to people
illegally making me not have to go to a
shitty part of town or deal with some
sort of criminal behavior to get the same
stuff.
No,
and it becomes a matter of priorities
when it comes to law enforcement like you
incompetent fucks.
Like why are you paying attention to this?
This is a non issue that hurts no
one and you're paying attention to,
that's the problem.
You know what think might happen?
I think this might get it legalized
in California if they start
closing the box wrong.
I think the potter did that
point come and go like,
oh,
okay,
we don't have,
but the issue is still stands.
It's not a stuck,
it's a federal issue.
It was what you don't understand
the federal government,
regardless of whatever the
state chooses is still,
they're shutting down
everywhere in America.
Well they're first starting supposedly
supposedly starting in San Diego cause I
guess San Diego is like one of those
areas where everyone around it,
there's a
very high,
uh,
like people don't want it there
as much as very conservative.
You go to her to make them open cell.
And so what now they're doing
is they're attacking the,
uh,
publications and like,
like newspapers and,
and for advertising it,
because supposedly there's
like this ridiculous law.
Like you're not allowed to advertise
anything that's illegal or illegal drugs.
You can't advertise cigarettes.
And I'm in magazines anymore.
Right.
You can't at all.
I don't think so.
Really.
I think it used to be no cartoons and
a lot of people and then it was like,
I don't think there's
just no bro whenever.
Wow.
Because they don't want the
sort of real live with it,
but it's sort of harmful.
I wonder what the numbers are as far as
p p p how much have people dropped off
of smoking cigarettes?
I've met a lot.
I bet.
I bet a lot.
I don't think kids are smoking as much.
I think it's,
you can't smoke in public places.
I think one of the biggest things for me,
it's back in the day,
you know you smoke cigarettes,
you could smoke in restaurants,
you could smoke anywhere.
Now it's kind of a tenure brand.
It can be a lot more
peer pressure moments.
Right,
exactly.
People still smoke,
but I have no idea if
it's less or more people.
This question,
according to that article in La Times
for 2007 American smoking rates declined
in the seven years leading up to 2004
but remained steady from 2004 to 2007
moms.
Largely due to a cut in funding for
smoke prevention programs and the things
that works.
Yeah.
Tobacco industry doubling its marketing
spending just to keep it even.
Yup.
Doesn't Ling tumbling since 1997 tobacco
consumption in developing countries has
increased at an annual rate of 1.7%
according to the UN Food and Agricultural
Organization.
The key,
the question is,
is that heavy marketing from
the tobacco industry has cow.
Okay.
So I,
wow.
It seems like steadied off when this
study was made whenever I'm 2007 but
when I was growing up,
my first high school,
there was no question
I would not be smoking.
And he was like,
I've never tried that.
Rarely do you meet other
kids and you're like,
oh well they're sort of
normal and they do it.
Okay.
Maybe I could.
Yeah,
I mean taking classes,
I would smoke.
I would go outside and smoke.
Really in high school.
Yeah.
We had this bridge that we
can just crawl underneath.
You kind of watch out for your health,
man.
That's why I freaked out and we w
I,
we have to talk about this in the podcast
because so many people got attached to
it on Twitter.
Our last a podcast we did,
Brian and I have little hissy fit because,
well I was tired and I was,
I was tired and uh,
I had been working a lot and um,
I had a short fuse and Brian was hammered
and that was hammered because I've been
doing this juice diet and on the way the
podcast.
So I wake up and I go to bed and I have
juice and so like I was in the car and
it awesome so far it's like,
let's drink.
And I'm like,
ah,
okay.
So we got like all this beer.
I had like three or four beers
and by the fourth beer I,
I was so to the,
have you listened to my voice?
I could barely talk.
I have no protein in me except everyone.
You'd honestly,
you're not slurring.
There's the way you always talk
that is used.
Brian gets pie.
I'd everyone always like,
what does he never wants you to draw?
Everybody else I talked to.
All right,
I'll be like,
I'm fucking,
I just happen off a beer and
like you get slurry fast.
Do you really think it has something to
do with that carbon monoxide poisoning
and you have no idea that really,
do you really think that you think
about that every now and then?
Did that,
do you know,
looking back at it,
it seems what I,
I guess you'd say the story again.
I rented out when I was in college.
I had this place and I had the top room,
which was like the attic,
but it was bad at it.
So I was like brick walls.
It was really bad as it was a
carbon monoxide was looking at them,
a brick walls on one site and then
would shitty windows on the other side.
And it was drafty.
And so,
uh,
there was only one heat vent
that came out of this brick that,
that I had my bed right
underneath cause I lived in Ohio,
so it's fucking cold.
And so like the heat would just come
out of this event and warm up the whole
entire room.
So yeah.
And uh,
when I was moving out,
the landlord was like,
you know,
going through to make sure
I didn't destroy anything.
And they go,
Whoa,
whoa.
Why is that thing not cover it up?
I'm like,
what the fuck you're talking about it?
And they're like,
no,
that's the carbon dioxide,
uh,
furnace,
you know,
output take that's
supposed to be covered up.
You know,
it's supposed to be
like a chimney exhaust.
Those two,
I cooked his brain.
I found that's why you slur.
He says he used to be able to talk better.
I think I,
I think it will.
What?
I think how I originally said it was like,
like,
yeah,
I think it definitely made me have a
slight little stutter or a little thing.
I don't think it drastic,
dramatically changed
anything over Manasseh.
Lauren,
I have no idea when you're drunk.
Crazy.
That is that you just said that you
think that sleeping in this house,
it might've given you a certain stutter.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean I'm just,
when you drink,
if you look at old videos of myself,
like I,
I think that it's nice.
It's nice to think that.
Right,
right.
It's also,
you look at old videos of me and I'm like,
no,
I'm just the same crazy person.
I've always been.
I talked to the exact same,
you know,
I just threw,
wrote something and this is a
good idea and this would help you.
Getting back to one of the,
we were talking about,
um,
being able to communicate and
I think a lot of this learn,
you know,
what would help you tremendously
if you would write things.
I really think if you been right,
I know,
I know what you're saying.
That it helps you,
it helps to form sentences,
better help form ideas.
Better is a,
an idea that somebody had on the message
board and it was a very astute idea.
And the guy said that when you write
and you get used to writing things,
it helps you form sentences and
phrases in your head better.
Yeah.
But you know,
when I'm,
when I'm out,
like off the air,
you know what,
I'm off the air.
I'm like at the Olive Garden,
I'm sorry,
Applebee's or wherever I'm at.
I'm just having a conversation
so I'm not stuttering.
I'm not,
not finishing sentences.
You're,
you're really,
you guys are all really focusing on me
getting really stoned and in two seconds
later sitting down and talking on a mic
mean.
I mean sometimes,
I mean I'm not talking
about just general talk,
I'm talking about like sometimes you
have an idea and you having a hard time
figuring out how to get,
cause I'm stone does not come to it when
you read a lot more to like go way up.
It does.
Yes.
Unquestionably.
But I also think right actress was stupid
actions is still sound really smart
because they read a lot cause
they read scripts all day long.
Yeah.
I have to read a bunch of them.
Just keep reading.
I'm an or an over and over and over
again and they're just like sure.
Say because they all thought about it.
Then you've known new
actresses it move out here.
Yes.
There are a lot of stupid hot chicks.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
A lot of them are.
Yeah.
And those go on to succeed.
Some of them.
I always wonder how much
is stupid and how much is,
they've never been exposed to anything
other than this narrow band of mental
operation.
They just stay in that.
So they come out of it whole entertainment
tonight.
Frequency
stay in that frequency.
What is that dumb or is that just they,
they're comfortable there because
otherwise I wouldn't watch it.
The news is on the other channel there's
some smart washer that like stupid
shit.
I know.
That's true.
It's got to be some stupid stuff.
Yeah.
That's okay.
I think there's more
crazy in Hollywood than of
it's fucking crazy.
It's ridiculous.
How much crazy like it makes me like when
you hang out with somebody that's not
crazy and you meet somebody new,
you're like,
oh my God,
this is,
I could see that this person's not crazy
and I had just hang out with crazy so
much that I feel like everybody is that,
you know?
Yeah.
There's so many Weirdos that hanging out
at the comedy store that you just sort
of take it for granted,
like a shocker lock off and you're like,
oh,
it's just normal part of your life.
Having to deal with those people
that whenever I was around that dude,
I was always ready to
kick him in the chest.
I was always ready for bum rushed to that.
Don't expect that he'll hit people and
fucking screaming drunk as shit from that
guy.
Two blocks for for a dollar.
He always Paul McGee,
bones wonky of guns.
He was so cool.
Uh,
cool.
Lighters,
lighters,
miters knives,
Robert William App or via
shockers hanging the crazy.
He's does he really still
so close to the show.
Joy Come my conversations
with Robert [inaudible].
He and I had a very
interesting little friendship.
He's,
he's uh,
schizophrenia I guess.
Yeah.
I don't know who,
he was always nice to me.
He was always complimentary.
He was always very a gentleman.
I'd be on this team then the other
team that people would torment them.
Yeah.
I don't think that's nice.
I don't think play along with your,
with your game,
but I'll just get on the good side.
I think he's a nice guy.
I know.
Excellent.
You're reached out my hand
to shake them recently.
I forgot.
I think I knew it,
but I forgot and he freaked the fuck out.
And I'm like,
I felt so bad because now he
thinks timeline on the bad side.
I think.
Oh No,
no,
I heard a people,
I'll talk to him for you.
So,
well
what do you guys have?
Like if I see and why would
it happy to talk to my luck.
Robert,
that would be funny though.
If you had like,
like conversations every
night at Hello Joe.
I was just,
I don't know his story,
but I apparently he was a like a lawyer,
right.
And he was,
uh,
went to Nyu,
play,
played on site.
Uh,
I think it played out like some sort
of like college basketball team.
Really.
Maybe the division to
city college or whatever.
But yeah.
Then we came out here
to do whatever you want.
Look crazy.
Wow.
Who said he thought he was gonna he
thought he was next in line to host it
tonight show.
Cause he'd attended more tapings of the
tight shot of Johnny Carson than anyone
else.
So he hates Jay Leno.
He hates all things.
He stole it from him.
He calls him lemon Jello.
He's got a weird disconnect.
But I don't know why.
I always enjoyed being around that guy.
If I have like a roach left,
you know,
and start throwing words like,
Hey Robert,
I want this kind of a pump,
which you very much,
I love how he even asks what
it is to really wants to know.
Great.
Who's the guy that he's
at the comedy store.
He always has like glasses
on and like this blonde,
weird shaggy hair and I'm like
a weird mustache or something.
I think he was a Ding Dong
or at one time the older guy.
But he's like,
I just found that like I
always in front of surfer.
No,
no,
no.
But it's like,
it's like that,
but this guy that it's like he's kind of,
you know,
on that,
that same kind of thing.
And I find out he's like
an action star in India.
Like number one of the
number one Indian accent.
He's been doing these videos
and they're like really popular.
And this whole time I'm like,
ah,
he's just this Ding Dong or guy.
They always hangs out here.
Wow.
Actions.
Yeah,
and if you look at the trailers,
uh,
it's amazing.
Like you're like,
it's the best thing you'll
ever see in your life.
God,
I don't know.
His name on show gets a weird group of
people how bearers controls and cr get
just finds them.
I don't know how he finds them.
Well,
what a commitment to,
he's been doing it for a decade.
You should have him on the show sometimes
way more like love to have barest
anytime you want to do it.
Well,
he's busy with his show.
Jimmy Kimmel show,
right?
Or something.
I love dawn Burris.
It's also gets off for like
a week at a tire there.
He's such a fun guy to be around.
He's helped me form a,
a unique part of my standup.
When I see him being goofy and
saying horrible things like,
oh,
how does he get away?
You watch them enough.
You're like,
okay,
I can sort of see a little bit of a smile.
He tells old ladies to be like,
Oh,
you filthy whore.
You love getting bent over and just rail,
don't you?
Dirty,
dirty whore.
And they love it.
They laughing,
they with their grandchildren,
the island,
while he's saying it,
he's smiling and laughing
while he's saying,
we had this door guy who
didn't understand that,
and I would always say like on stage,
he's like,
Hey,
what's up?
Black people or there was going to like
interact with black people and bears are
always like,
you bitch,
how dare,
but in a fun way.
That's Dork.
I didn't get it.
And one day he just goes up with
some woman from in the audience,
from onstage and he goes,
what's up you black bitch?
And it ruined.
Then that's five hours of show.
Oh No,
it wasn't there.
It was like,
what's with that room?
No,
Kyle,
that's what they call them.
Sick Kyle.
Oh God.
Kyle,
Kyle nickname doctor.
That just didn't know how to do it right.
Bad for him.
There's a lot of nut heads
working at that place.
If there was ever a
vortex of insane people,
it's the comedy store.
Yeah.
So many nutty fucking
humans in that choice.
We're like,
how do you even survive in life?
Kind of crazy.
Yeah.
And I know you're just here,
just one of the people
here and in that place.
There's a lot of those people
that are still regulars on,
they still go on stage.
You know,
you can go there and it's,
you'll see half a show and half
like a psychology experiment.
Dude crab.
It's goes up there sometimes
and it's so hard to take.
What happened to him.
He just fried,
he's fried and it just like,
it used to be like,
yeah,
he used to be funny.
He used to be a funny guy when I saw him,
he was like on the tail end of that and
then I don't think he's used anymore,
but I think you're just caught up
and it just like you're burnt out.
No brain left.
Yeah.
He has this horrible stories.
It'll just start on you midway through
a story and you just traps you.
Oh No,
she's so sad and on stage
just becomes so horrible.
There's been a couple times lately that
had been going there and this is like
prime,
not prime I guess,
but like,
you know,
Sunday 10:00 PM nine 30 nice crowd in the
audience of like friends of the comedy
store,
just like maybe it was,
I'm sorry Monday it was Monday,
but same kind of thing.
Right.
But there was,
there's,
this is uh,
like two comics in a row that I watch
and I got angry because they had like 10
minutes spots at this time and you know,
it was the worst thing ever.
The crowd just sitting there like,
really?
Are we watching this awful shit?
And I get mad.
I had to leave.
The weird thing about those nights,
well you've seen them.
So the open mic,
it's like they've sat
through so much shit,
but at some point they just
lose faith and stand up.
So if you go all like the employees
are going right after that.
Yeah.
And they're like,
what are you going to do to us now?
It was so hard.
God,
that's exactly what it is.
It's like beaten.
You can't just keep beating every,
every host.
Just be like,
all right,
that's nice guy.
Really funny and at some point when I,
I never said that because I'm like,
they're not going to believe me after
you say five times in a row and say this
guy and the worst things ever,
unless the guy's really funny.
Yeah.
Never say he's really fun.
Then one time,
but like,
hey guys,
by the way,
I know there's been a shit show.
It's been madness of
homeless people right now,
but this guy is funny.
You can say that.
Yeah.
Fuck.
They would get so hard.
I used to have to host that like years.
I would host such very good for your act.
Yeah.
It was for yours and how to apply.
It helped you as a Freddy said the
first time you went to let me do it.
He goes,
if she lets you do it more than once,
watch how much quicker
it makes her onstage.
Every three minutes.
I got to get back up there and start
thinking of something to get the crowd
going away and you also
learn how to manage the room,
becomes sort of a social manager.
Keep all these people,
you know,
I have to keep doing like in between
everybody to make him laugh at 30 seconds
to figure out how to make them laugh
fast and then bring on the next awful
awful,
awful types from actually
used to love comics.
Like boom,
Shaka Laka who would go on in drag with
a bucket on his head and you know what?
At least he got the crowd going and you
see how the crowd at least after him,
like he'd be like,
keep that going for the next guy.
But didn't you ever want to just sterilize
that fucking microphone after you're
done?
Dude,
I still worse.
That's,
that's probably the worst thing ever.
Sometimes I totally
forget to when I'm like,
oh I just touched my
microphone.
That'll never gets clean.
Never.
And they don't find new ones.
Cool.
They've been there for a while.
One that's there.
It's probably the one that I bought.
It has to a blown up completely before
they replaced that cheap content,
just sucking that shit out of it.
I've always found my,
and I think about it later,
I'm like,
that's terrible cause it smells.
Sometimes even through the night enough
people have the little spittle laying on
it just thinks,
damn.
I was going to talk about,
oh this,
I read some fucking studies as strangers
study that I've ever read and it's a
bunch of scientists that are convinced
that there is no free will and that the
moment you decide and make up your
mind to do something in reality,
you had already decided
several seconds before this,
she talks about those,
did you talks about it?
He said,
the thing is you can't tell yourself up.
Think of an elephant like
what made you say to yourself,
think of an elephant you're making,
you're making.
There is no independent thought.
It's cool and I really don't fully
understand it because a lot of what I
understand about it could be completely
opposite from the way my take on it
because I thought about it.
I'm like,
this is a fascinating thing because you
essentially have philosophers that are
arguing with scientists and in a sense
they're both right because maybe you,
you don't change what you're doing.
Maybe maybe you know,
there is no real freewill,
but maybe it's because the seven
second thing that happens before you,
you know,
you make up your mind to whatever the
choice is going to be that you're gonna
pick.
Maybe that's just a random thing,
but the results of that,
maybe that's what they can't measure the
results or you change the way you think
and that essentially is free will the
freewill but already changed the way you
think they're,
that's what they're saying.
They're not accounting for character.
And I don't think it's an either or
because I think that certain amount of
character and certain amount
of will can be developed.
And the essential question
is why you develop again,
where you designed to develop it as just
just your natural course of your life
that you're following,
that you're supposed to follow anyway.
And you are just tricking yourself into
thinking these are your own decisions.
But this is almost like laid out right
where it's like you're going to make this
decision,
this is what you're going
to struggle with it,
and then they come to this.
Imagine they have under
further investigation,
they show that there really is a code
that already set up picking out through
the air and that code is like a genetic
code or like a computer code and that
it's,
it's a wireless frequency that we're
tuned into that is moving us in a very
specific program to do
a exactly what we do.
If this is what they're saying,
if they're saying that you know your,
your mind has made moves to to make
this decision seven seconds before you
consciously decided
that he says about God,
where it's like if God knows what we're
going to end up doing because there's no
time to God.
Yeah.
In the normal concept of God,
then there's no free will.
He knows what we're going to do.
He knows we're going to make a decision
this way or that way and this is the
best way.
I was explained how that maybe it's
not the best way of thinking about it.
If you go and see Jurassic Park with
someone who's never seen it before and you
say,
Oh,
this guy's about to get killed
and then he gets killed,
your friend is going to be like,
why did you make that dinosaur to do that?
Like you didn't do it.
You just know what's going to happen.
It doesn't mean it doesn't
mean you're commanding me.
It's a,
it's a very interesting concept.
No,
no,
no.
It's an interesting concept because I
want to believe that I'm in control of my
life.
You want to assure,
you know,
and we all do,
but why do we,
why do we want to absolutely believe
that we're not just following some Howard
determined pattern of behavior power.
I want to be leaders,
not followers.
Well,
sort of,
but like when you're at your best,
like say on stage,
you know,
we talk about like being in that groove,
you're not,
you're like a passenger.
You're like riding that fucking thing,
right?
That's when you are at your best,
When it's not,
you're not really even thinking about,
not even in control.
He just sort of floating best.
Did it ever say shine?
Shine?
Yeah.
The movie about the pianist that work,
that goes crazy.
It's the guy who won the Oscar.
He,
he did some Holocaust movie later.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
I know who you're talking about.
Yeah,
whatever.
The little kid one,
he learned it,
but they said when he was playing the
thing and all you hear the sound drop off
and all you hear is the
bumping of the keys,
the physical keys hitting his fingers,
you know,
cause everything goes quiet.
It's like that's how it sort of feels
like when you're in the zone on stage
where it's ever,
you're just sort of like,
Huh,
and now I'm saying this and those
people are reacting this way.
Right,
and you're,
you're,
you're floating through it.
You're not even conscious.
Oh,
look at that.
Look at what,
I just sit there and you can't even
think about that too much because that'll
distract you.
But it's like you're
just going on autopilot.
It's like boogie boarding.
You just catch away and just keep going.
Well,
you know,
that's the concept of also the muse.
The idea of creativity coming
as something you tune into.
It just hits you and it's all so
maybe that is all really connected.
We talked about that.
When you get a great bit,
you're just like,
I just sort of came to me.
I didn't do it out of the air
just comes out of the ether.
You have to sit yourself
down to to receive it.
That's what you gotta do.
That's what I was saying.
You should write.
You know,
cause I think you have a
lot of really funny ideas,
but you keep them all in your head.
You know,
you bounce him out on stage and you write
things down that you're going to do.
But I think if you wrote a blog,
like a funny blog,
I think you would really get into it.
And I have some really funny shit and
it would really help your stand up.
It really helps your,
your word,
you're forming sentences and it
really helps your material because
you,
when you sit down to write a blog,
at least for me when I write,
I just,
I never restrict myself,
you know,
unless I'm working on this particular
bit that I'm trying to tighten up.
I don't restrict myself to like what
subject or how I'm going to do it.
I just start writing.
Like if maybe it'll come out funny,
maybe it will come out creepy.
Maybe it'll come out.
Yeah.
We just write just whatever the fuck I'm
thinking and as you're writing then you
know,
it's like,
it takes longer to write the word
neuroscientists that it does to think of a
neuroscience,
but it makes you keep thinking about it.
Right.
It makes me think about it.
But it's almost in the ideas like it's
richer in your mind as just sitting down
and just think,
just thinking without actual pen.
Yeah.
When you actually write things down,
there's something to it I
think where it enriches the,
it's hard to keep your compensation to
like if you're thinking about whatever it
is,
I don't know this call,
we were trying to write a bit about skills
without writing it down about putting
a pen to paper,
write your mind then wanders to something
else and you're no longer doing the
writing about the thing.
That's why I've said it before.
I'll say it again.
That right room application is the shit.
If you have a Mac,
it's called right room and I know
there's a PC a variation before,
but I'm on team Mac so you can suck it.
The best real world advice I
got on writing came from uh,
Damon Wayans actually wants the,
I'm starting.
Yeah,
because people said like,
oh,
it's so helpful.
So that's what the problem
is in everybody's brains.
There's a laziness where it's like,
yeah,
but what am I going to write for an hour?
Like I'm never going to fucking do that.
Whereas what he said in the morning,
before you go to work,
you take 10 minutes and set an alarm.
If it's 1102,
when you're starting set of for 1113.
So as that next minute
start to get 10 minutes,
as soon as the alarm goes off,
stop writing and you
always have 10 minutes,
you can put in 10 minutes.
It goes,
one of two things happens.
One,
uh,
if you do have more time,
you'll keep writing if you want to.
So we'll get it going already
to the rest of the day.
You're thinking about what
you're already put on paper.
So you're going to keep
writing in your head.
You're going to keep that,
that,
uh,
the brain just pumping.
You know what I mean?
But you can always spare 10
minutes who always keep doing it.
I haven't,
let me get home.
You can write more if you want,
but just every morning,
10 minutes.
And it seems so foolish.
If you can't put in 10 minutes.
It does.
And I don't
very specific,
um,
set a mindset when it comes to
anything that's going on in my life,
especially with stand up and,
and anything creative.
If I'm not writing,
I never completely feel in the zone.
Like I will have to sit myself down.
Like if I have like a gig coming up,
like let's say I'm doing a theater and
the weekend I have to sit myself down and
write something.
I have to sit myself down and get that
part of my brain just crank it up.
Here's an idea,
here's something I'm working on.
Even if I don't talk about that on stage,
but you're still,
the fact that I'm working on new
shit just puts you in a better mood.
Better brain move.
Makes me feel productive.
It makes me feel like I'm,
I'm,
I'm putting out what I'm neat
when I'm supposed to put out.
I believe you also feel like confident
or like a winner because you wrote and so
that helps your that's yeah.
Well I think when you do what you know
you're supposed to feel like a loser.
I got made a non paid regular.
Mitzi and maybe just like I was allowed
to do belly room shows or something.
Right.
But my sets around town over my expert
just killer for like three weeks,
cause I felt like I'm a real comic.
Yeah.
But it didn't make my writing any better.
I was still doing the same jokes.
And they have told me that when he got
his black belt from February see over
doom,
he immediately became
better on the ground.
And Ryan Parson said that too.
They were just thinking he deserved it.
Yeah.
We just started like going,
he just started putting in his head like,
yeah man,
I'm a fucking black belt in Jujitsu.
Shit.
Yeah Ma'am is a legit,
and you go for it said to a
man may ham's ground game is,
and no fucking joke when you
think it was fight with business.
It's a great fight side.
You know,
it's a great fight.
It's an interesting fight.
It's a fucking,
the coaching and the show is what's been
the most impressive thing about Ma'am
to me.
I was,
uh,
we were texting each other
back and forth today.
I was like,
dude,
you're a fucking good coach man.
He's a really good coach.
Like his instructions are very clear.
Post up,
post up.
Alright.
Lefthand could get his controls risk.
Good,
nice,
nice.
It's like everything is steady.
Walks the guys through it,
get them in an elbow ain't got,
yeah,
and he's like,
all right,
he's breaking now he's break
and he's looking to quit.
He's looking at a quick,
I mean he talked his fighters
through the entire thing.
Get its back right.
Flatten them out,
flatten them out.
Alright,
soften them up.
He's done.
Let's finish.
Let's finish late.
And they understand that
this thing is screaming
Freeman at the top of his lungs and he's
so mad because may one every fucking
fight.
So Bisbing business fighters just getting
checked and may is talking to dudes
through it perfectly.
It was,
it was amazing.
I was like,
damn,
that just shows people it may have is
really all about when those fights the
same time as they're doing the fight
now as the coaches are fighting.
No,
no.
That's the next in the next integration.
When we do it on Fx,
then it's going to be in lifetime.
You mean December 3rd
is that what you mean?
Yes,
but normally eventually
it's going to be live.
They're going to have,
the fights are going to
be live on telephone.
Television used to do it on a different,
oh,
really?
Every week.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know how they're
going to synchronize that.
They're figuring it out with Fx,
but that's going to be amazing.
Wow.
But Damn,
these 135 pounders,
145 pounds are fucking awesome.
Brian has the best idea for that.
It goes.
It's just so small.
He says,
I should come in and prance around the
octagon on ponies and make it the reason
I knew Brian Red Bell.
You said that all adorned.
Then I'll let you ride a favor,
send you all adorned and the one 35
was it have to move around with us.
That would be awesome.
Horns and stuff.
I can't participate in that for that
and I feel like little lines
and then they're lying.
Crossers
flux are,
I don't even know what to do.
That little prancing when
it gets down on one knee,
like
very regal.
Would it be a pony with
the hair over the hubs
to be an extra blessing and to have that
extra hair that just blossoms run their
Budweiser ponies.
So what the fuck is that
one of the fighter route is
that man weird fucking dust
covers they have over their feet and shit.
That man their feet.
Somebody make that,
they invent that horse.
It's like dog breeding.
They just,
that's all they could do with horses.
Is that what they did?
Maybe.
Right.
Well the,
a bunch of different breeds.
Apparently we were wrong.
And the Indians,
a new agriculture before the,
uh,
the white man and they taught the
white man had to grow corn and uh,
be,
they apparently might have even had
horses before European settlers,
but the ink is didn't,
the Incas didn't know
about the horse cause,
but there might've been some
other horses that were left.
They also think that the,
the first settlers in America
might've been the Chinese.
Really?
Yeah.
The Chinese might have found
from the Bering strait.
Yeah,
no,
yeah,
we do that.
We've got the one.
No,
no,
no.
Not that.
The Siberians I mean,
on boats.
Yeah.
There's,
there's a,
I believe there's,
there's a bunch of pump,
you know,
there's a bunch of history
that's obviously lost in
North America because North
America used to be covered in a glacier
and the gray shirt fucking crushed
everything and melted and created
the Great Lakes and all that shit.
But there,
the other thing I mostly Filipinos
and they'll always look somewhat,
you know,
Mexican,
they look sort of Mexican for the Asians.
And I talked to Edwin San Juan
yesterday and it was like,
yeah,
the Spanish came and rape
the fuck out of both the,
my name is Edwin San Juan San Juan,
and I'm an Asian.
Yeah.
Crazy.
Well that's a Filipinos.
It's a weird,
it's a Chinese and the
Chinese and Spanish.
So they must have,
the Chinese must have like,
just when not the Asians must
have just gone on both that way.
Going West,
we were going use,
they found cocaine,
they found cocaine residue in
some Faroes something or another.
They found evidence of
cocaine use in ancient Egypt.
And what's insane about that as cocaine
can only be grown in South America,
can't be growing and in relationships.
Yeah,
the climate doesn't suit it.
I don't know.
Part of the time they think that
they might've been on a fucking ship.
The other possibility is
that the climate was way,
way different back then.
I don't know if that,
I'm sure they have a pretty
detailed record of the can also be,
weren't,
didn't some people used to bring stuff
from other parts of the world we,
yeah,
but they were saying by boats,
they didn't know that people
were traveling the globe.
That that mean that we are
talking about 2,500 BC,
but we do know that they
have boats back then.
There's some really detailed
boats that they found in tombs,
like incredible boats,
like big giant put together
boats inside tombs,
you know,
so that we know that they could get on,
maybe not,
you know,
across the ocean,
but they could,
they were,
they definitely had the
concept of boats down,
you know?
Yeah.
But yeah,
I was just going to say,
so the people that like that,
like live in North America,
I'm like,
this whole thing used
to be covered in ice,
so there's not,
there's not that many
people that were here.
Everybody sort of eventually went,
oh,
this is open now.
And then,
then people stormed in there,
just jumped,
look at all the space.
It's crazy,
crazy how it happened.
If you look at like the
evolution of the earth,
you know,
and like the progress of
people moving around it.
A very strange thing that
this one awesome spot that uh,
used to be connected to everything
was completely empty except for it's,
you said a few tribes have no,
yeah.
Really.
I mean there's just a tiny,
tiny number.
So much extra real estate.
Yeah.
It's what a crazy,
go somewhere else with it.
We go with the Buffalo.
Go to,
let's wait.
Where's your house for though?
With the buffalo is for the short period
of time that when the Indians were like
in the,
like in the best situation before the
white men found out what the fuck was over
here.
This must've been the dopest playground.
Aw.
Yeah.
They had a whole continent.
Talk about too far.
Is this Christ big foot's well,
yeah.
There's a lot of things that can kill
you and Jaguars and shit like that.
What's really crazy is that just 10,000
years ago there were saber tooth tigers.
Wrap your head around that.
That's just town thousand years ago.
Long three points.
Yeah.
Cool.
But don't want to be cool.
Wild fucking animal.
That was,
it had swords and its skull big giant
swords that came out and it would just
slash open your neck with these sores.
Both lifestyle.
Yeah.
Eyeball pop out care.
You're fucking both fighters style.
You see that video or the video to the
image of the bull fighter that got Gordon
Spain was brain his face through his face.
Right through his eyeball.
It shows the horn popping out.
These was out?
No,
no,
it's paralyzed,
uh,
paralyzed that side of his face.
It's amazing how quick it happened
to the videos or it's just like,
just having goes down here,
you see the gazelle leaping over the guys.
Oh my God,
I heard them talking about
that or the other day,
this gaming guy from wherever that was.
Explain what it is.
Oh,
okay.
Because not everybody lives.
Zol has six players.
There's this,
there's this bike path in South Africa,
South Africa and it's in like the
reservation are reserved for animals.
Yeah.
And this gazelle,
just,
this guy's taping his buddy ahead of them
and they're both biking and this cause
they'll just suddenly runs in a screen,
tries to jump over this biker
as he's speeding down this path.
Yeah.
Just,
he doesn't see the guy coming in quick
enough and the Gazelle runs into him or
whatever.
It knocks it down.
Big deer like animal,
but hit him full clip going
like 40 miles an hour.
He goes flying lands on his fucking
head and then noises he was making.
It was like,
Hey,
oh noises.
That's Kao noises.
When someone gets knocked out of it,
when they're waking up,
they make noise.
Like you see his helmet,
his helmet shattered,
just a hole in it.
We're like,
yeah,
that's what that was.
Or your brain would look like right
now if you weren't wearing a home,
that's scary as fuck dude.
Get the hose hit dead on.
Yeah,
he could've died for sure if he didn't
have a helmet on his head and up and
smushy they said this,
this reserve guys said the sun
was probably in the gazelles.
I angle was coming in that way or
whatever and he just saw him at the last
second because he was speeding
faster than normal I guess.
So it was just like,
you know,
he just timed it and they saw
him and let's try to jump over.
There's a great video.
Online wasn't a tie.
This is a great video in line of a guy
on a motorcycle with a camera in the
front of his motorcycle.
He's carving through canyons
and he hits a deer and you see one
frame where you see the deer's face.
Oh,
fucking bad ass.
Boom.
And he just goes fucking fine.
And you see the camera flying
through the air and spins,
and then it goes black.
And then it shows the
guy he actually survived.
He got laid out,
his bike is destroyed,
and he just flipped and,
but he was wearing,
you know,
it actually says,
make sure you were always
wear a helmet and we're,
we're leather men.
He was like covered in like a,
you know,
like one of those racers,
Tom outfits that you can actually kind
of take a little bit of an impact with it
on.
It's not because you're sliding down.
That's what happened.
A Harris,
it was sliding down the street
and just ripping the skin off.
But when you hit it,
you hit a deer and 60 miles an hour.
It ain't that like,
it's sliding.
You're going flying,
you're,
you're going to fly through the air.
Everything's flying.
You don't know what the
fuck is going to happen.
You just hit a deer and it's just,
you're going way too fast.
You took on that speed,
you're on something
that's like 3000 pounds,
but no,
not that heavy.
What is it?
What does a motorcycle or whatever,
but he's a hundred pounds,
500 pounds,
600 pounds,
one of those like Ninjas or you're just,
your body goes that fast.
It's like you're going 60 miles an hour.
You keep going 60 it's ridiculously fast.
Those things are so crazy.
You know,
I see them on the highway
sometimes just fucking by
the weirdest thing ever that that's legal.
I mean this is like what
a massive risk taking of,
we have a high waist in
California for people don't know.
Most rational states
all across this country.
You have to stay in your fucking lane.
All right?
You can't just drive in the middle.
In California,
they let motorcycles drive in between
the fucking cars and I dunno who says
that's okay and they often hit your
side mirrors and it happened twice.
I've had it happen.
They just go right through it.
Especially those dudes are those
big crazy fat Harley bikes.
You know those things
aren't that nimble man.
What are those guys even trying like
the ones with the big ass like that.
The storage containers on the side
trying to go in between lanes.
What is this?
What's up with these handlebars?
I don't know.
These handlebars where
they look like they're,
they're like lower,
lower,
no more rocky on the top of the stairs.
In Philadelphia they get more
attention because it's like,
hey,
look at me.
I'm on allow motorcycle cycle for person
fruit folks looking or not looking or
rather listening at home.
We're doing the arms up in the air
thing where they call them hangars,
ape hangers.
That's what they call them.
The crazy handlebars
that are like super tall,
right to live,
live the ride.
Your motorcycle motorcycles
must be so much fucking fun.
Now think about it.
People get together in groups and
they all just ride around together.
I want to get that fat tire one,
the one that has the really,
that's a big one.
Get the trials handling call dude.
The Tri Cycle one.
I think those fat tire ones
are just kind of cool looking.
But I think if you want
a bike that handles,
you know,
mean a sport bike is like a bike
that would handle really good.
But like,
you know,
you get like a balanced road bike.
This tricycle motorcycles look fine.
I need them to not be as,
uh,
as dom looking to,
you know,
tries to go motorcycles.
Yeah,
they do look a little look at me.
Yeah.
Somebody does fat Tuesday
has Corey Holcomb.
Cory does.
And it's like,
what is this?
Yeah,
you're talking about an aren't ya?
Oh,
that's all.
Is that what it is?
You're talking about it.
So he got ya.
He likes it.
Oh,
that's funny.
So much attention toward
that dude's really funny.
He's hilarious.
When does he have a
special or anything out?
I Dunno.
Ideas always talks about how he was
talking about when we did the NAB show in
Toronto two years ago.
I was like summer before this one,
um,
that he had this bit about,
the worst thing about your girl having
a miscarriage is that you have to act
upset.
Oh he's acts out it
does happen.
And he does it for like
a while and then you see,
I'm like reaches handover and go gosh
flush.
That's hilarious.
Yeah that's a for I hear your,
your pain about one and a
half of a sack to me I feel.
Yeah.
You know a lot of comments.
I got roped in over there.
No.
Oh yeah,
no though we all know them and we all
know what happens but becomes their life
when it's just a weird thing that you
get connected to someone like you.
They're inescapable.
And we were supposed to hook up three
times and that was supposed to be it for
our story.
We're not supposed to be
spending 30 years together.
Yeah,
that's a weird thing man.
It's a weird thing.
They're getting that operation.
Just the print out some fake medical
records saying that you have a past family
history.
Here's the weird thing.
So every time I hear something like that,
like the only real excuse to not do it,
it's something ridiculous like that.
It's almost like joking.
No,
no.
Just how you do they have with case farms,
you just in it.
I mean if it's got,
we're going to think in terms of that.
You could definitely have a mastectomy.
I think they have a pill for men
that they're working on it forever.
Since I was,
since I just started fucking,
I would think that it's going
to kill your deck though.
I would think.
Did any pill that just the board said,
yeah,
I think any pill that probably
like it's going to affect your day.
What if they cut it with like
Viagara 90% so it's like,
hey,
whatever.
Everything good.
Could you imagine if that happened and uh,
only sole as babies were born.
It's not that starts the apocalypse.
It's not only conceive soulless babies,
they come out with fucking Parana teeth.
You just need the way out of the post.
No eyeballs.
Yeah.
That's what starts it.
There's so many different scenarios
as to what's going to start it.
What's going to start the Zombie apart.
We all agree it's going to start.
There will be a Zombie
apocalypse at some point.
Well we all know that there's too
many fucking people for the amount of
resources that we have in this one area
that we've all chosen to reside in and
eventually that Shit's going to fall
apart if we don't figure out this whole
petro chemical dependency thing.
We're eventually gonna
run out of fucking oil.
I mean,
whether it's a 500 years from now
or 10 years grand scheme of it,
we're running oil,
there'll be mass extinction and it start
over with the amount of people we can
handle with no oil.
Good luck with all that.
He loved the walking
home and smelling rotten.
Good luck.
20 to 40 hours joy that shit and worrying
about who's going to eat your dog
tonight.
You know,
cause they need those times and then you
smell it cooking and you look over the
window and you see your fucking neighbors
chewing on your dog looking like
fucking monster.
Like I hate my fucking dog hungry.
Yeah.
People got gonna start eating dogs.
I think I was studying people.
We're going to realize we're going
to have to eat some of each other.
There's just too many to go around.
That's where mad cow comes from.
Cows eating each other in the
grand cow disease comes from,
it's called Jacob's Crutchfield.
I think that's the name of the
official name of the disease.
Um,
it comes from cows being forced,
fed brain tissue can on the grant.
And this same exact disease
manifests itself amongst cannibals.
When cannibals eat their,
uh,
their rivals brains,
they get sick,
but then realized that,
that you get the shakes.
Yes.
The book of Eli is,
it wasn't.
So that wasn't a movie.
The book of your life in the mood.
Yeah,
that's true,
dude.
That's right.
I may or may not have been in the book.
Probably wasn't in the original,
but it is true.
The same shitty ending of the book.
Why did I watch this
whole thing with this?
That was a brutal ending in
to find out that he's blind.
I don't see it doesn't pay off.
He's blind the whole time,
but he's not really the
whole things in Braille.
And he's the only one that can read it.
It's got the message of the Bible.
That's what he was living for us.
So we can move,
make the Bible live along.
And by the way,
what's the translation
is an ancient Hebrew,
all English,
all English.
She's given the gift.
Who knows it by heart.
All English to fucking cunts.
How dare he,
I can put it in a library,
but it is a thing.
Apparently that is the disease
when people get the shakes.
Yeah.
From that,
there was something else we talked
about last week that we shouldn't,
I don't know if you knew about that.
I funds not being built this time around
in China really being built in Brazil.
Riley,
this new iPhone is being built in Brazil.
Brazil.
Hopefully they don't have as many.
So we were talking about sweatshops.
I don't,
I don't know man.
I think they took a lot of heat
from what happened in China.
They,
they have these Foxconn studios,
right?
It's Foxconn studios at 420,000 people
working 15 hours a day for $175 a month
and no air conditioning
and hot fucking China.
And does anyone have air
conditioning in China
like that?
Real?
They know it exists.
It's not like a ghost.
I read this thing that they were talking
about Perry or Romney or one of those
guys wherever first Massachusetts.
I literally don't care
about politics at all,
but some of it interests me.
But like,
uh,
there were saying how,
oh,
well the unemployment premiums went
up there up to 14% in Massachusetts.
So that shows how bad they are.
That 43% higher than the national average.
And then somebody like,
yeah,
but when I institute this thing,
it was 20% over.
It's down to 14%.
You can't just say,
I don't know why.
What were you saying that
I just thought of this,
uh,
the people in Foxconn.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
It was like,
what if no one in China has
air conditioning and it's not,
that sounds way worse,
but yeah.
But either way,
that's extreme.
Hundred 70 bucks a month.
You're so cheap and a family of
suicide and suicide nets all around the
building.
So this conversation you have
to decide that's wow that,
that there's like millions
of people that work there.
It's all this conversation.
Yet there's millions of people there
that that the rate is actually lower than
the national average.
The national average that's,
yes,
it is.
It is.
Is that it's actually 420,000 people
that are employed there and their rate is
slightly below the national rate.
Wow.
So really it's not about them being like,
oh look how bad the other,
you have to have suicide notes.
I was like,
no,
no.
Look how above and beyond
they're going lead.
The real question is how many of
those people kill themselves at work?
[inaudible]
right,
exactly.
That's why it's depressing.
It's funny.
How many times have you heard like
post office and his guys going in and
shooting up the place or
just happen at Seal Beach?
Supposedly one of the employees just
killed like eight people there at that an
employee.
I thought that was a boyfriend.
Oh,
was it?
I thought it was a guy that worked there.
I could see wanting to kill yourself.
If you work in an album,
I don't know that an apple
plant for months and months
and they come in one day.
It's like guys,
big announcement and if it
stops working for a second,
it's like we're,
we're here.
We just got a great review
and the Gawker and be like,
oh,
okay,
excuse me,
and just go up to the roof
and just fucking ended.
It hasn't,
you know,
I think it's probably
one of these things that,
yeah,
whatever they're making like
$200 a month or whatever it is.
Even once every fuck once if I,
I think if anything it's,
it's probably in around them like how
much does rice costs and things like that.
You know what I mean?
It's,
you can get a hold back
for $5 first of all,
I know where you live sucks horribly,
but you don't need to escape.
Well,
what do you want to retirement?
you can retire on a bag of rice and it's
also giving them a place to live though
too,
which is not most jobs.
Yeah,
you might get paid shitty,
but you're awesome at getting,
you know,
getting into live.
Do you're living in a dormitory
stacked on top of each other that,
and there's,
they're not making enough money
to like buy a house somewhere.
I mean,
what are they gonna do?
They're just going to get wrung out to
dry drained of your humanity just so that
we can have phones,
but what are,
what are,
what are the other Pete,
which is we're where that factory is or,
or their houses or people living in
like on boats is a good question.
Like,
you know,
maybe that reality is so much better
than the Zombie apocalypse that they were
living in before this fucking Chinese
sweatshop factory opened up and they're
probably getting medical on that.
I'm not sure if they do.
They probably are.
Everybody sort of wants to say like,
well,
maybe if it's,
everything is okay,
but the reality is it's sweatshop itself.
It is a sweat shop.
You don't hire children in America.
Right.
We had to make a law and it sucks what
other people do pay them shittily and
it's like,
yeah,
of course we're going to have it there.
It's cheaper.
And then you realize Microsoft,
Sony,
every single fucking company
does the exact same thing.
Even at Fox con.
Well that's,
you know,
it's really interesting is I try,
I said,
I wrote this on Twitter and I wrote us on,
on the message board.
I said,
what about a phone called the iPhone Karma
and what it is is a phone that's made
in America.
You pay people a good wage.
Yeah,
you pay them a good wage and I'll pay
double for your phone and you're better to
have a sticker where everyone else can
see that you're paying fucking sell
hundreds
be such a great lesson that it might not,
it might not be a moneymaker.
No.
You know,
they would never do it.
One of the guys that have maybe also be
admitting that they were doing something
bad on the other end.
Exactly.
One of the guests were message boards
said that they should have an iPhone Karma
and then an iPhone.
I think he's evil tyranny as and it's
like super cheap and is support the dark
lord as they fucking drop bombs
from olive green color to it.
It's made out of flesh of Afghany babies.
Even even like the shirts,
they even tee shirts and clothing,
like half of that shit.
It comes from even worse
conditions than Foxconn,
you know?
I Dunno.
I mean it's really weird to wear.
Where do you prioritize?
You know,
obviously it's horrible that there's
war going on right now and civilians and
Afghanistan and Iraq are
dying and they didn't.
It's not their fucking fault.
And the whole thing is chaos.
You can only pick one.
What can you do good things to think
about that you have to go did a countries,
they countries have to
make it last and be like,
look,
no,
this is illegal.
You have to fucking have these
conditions and got by our rules.
They don't.
They won't do it.
We're not worth anything anymore,
man.
We're broke.
We're broke as fuck.
I don't even understand how that works.
I understand how it works.
I finally figured it out.
Tell these fucking podcasts.
Nobody's working anymore.
90% of you listening right
now just going to shut up.
Shut up.
You're going to ruin hitch.
Yeah.
There was all listen to
podcasts all day long at work.
It's motherfuckers ruin
everything I think.
I think we should just
have a country bias out.
That's what's the most expensive country,
right?
We might be the most successful,
which is the scariest thing.
That means that the banks of the
really key ones controlling everything.
If everybody's fucking broke,
everybody's proud.
There's that one country where
everybody's just fucking Bawling Jz style,
24 seven in their underwear,
popping bottles with models
and the top of a yacht.
No one's doing that.
Not One country.
Then how is anybody winning
and if nobody's winning,
where does all the resources go?
You kind of who's got the money?
Who's got the papers?
You've got to just,
it's my problem with the occupy,
occupy Wall Street stuff.
I just don't quite understand.
I like the rising up and
stating your mind and stuff.
I just don't understand who
you're picketing forward,
what results you're hoping for.
Well,
they want change and I don't know,
but the super rich,
they're the ones,
I mean,
are they going to be like,
oh,
I'm to not affecting me in any way.
The good thing is what they're,
they're doing is getting people to think
that this is a very unstable situation
and because it is and that people are
fed up because they are and they should
be.
This is a fucking
terrible financial system.
It's horrible.
I don't understand it.
I know that billions of dollars had been
thrown around in the form of bailouts
and some say much more than that if
you follow the accounting because yeah,
they forced the force an audit and Ron
Paul had something to do with this and
they shout out,
there was just fucking,
just insane amounts of money loaned to
all these different creepy clients all
over the world and bailouts just put
in left and right and it's all our tax
money,
man.
It's all scary.
They spent all our fucking money and
we're broke and we're in two wars at the
same time.
And no one has any solution that seems
to want to deviate from the current path.
Everyone's solution is stay on the
current path and manage it better.
So then there,
except Ron Paul,
what does he know?
He has a better solution.
What's his,
how he wants everybody back.
He's like,
this is ridiculous.
Yeah,
and because of that,
they don't even pay attention to him.
There's this new guy
that they're following.
It was this black guy,
the black guy.
Herman pain.
Is that what his name is?
Haven't we had enough?
I just kidding.
He's a black Republican.
They sent,
said they've sent in Mothra to battle
with Godzilla or he's not going to run.
Fuck Jay's run.
He's the black guys ahead.
Oh,
he's a head right now.
Yeah.
Okay.
We need to find out if you ever
thought about robbing and shooting up.
This guy is different.
He's such a Republican treatment.
He says that if a,
you don't have a job,
that's your fault.
Wow.
And that's okay.
If you're not rich,
it's your fault.
Have you ever thought about doing that,
Joe?
Just like,
you know,
when he was retiring
in a different country,
I'm,
I'm fucking Cat Stevens.
Sing out was in France.
Mostly it's us cars or cars or
traditionally our conditioning.
Herman Cain,
that's his name.
Herman Cain.
He's a very successful businessman,
but I think a lot of those
occupy wall should be,
we want to do away with capitalism as a,
you know?
Yeah.
There's a lot of Hippie bitches
out there that need a punch.
I think that's their problem.
It's like why should 1% habit,
we should all be equal in this long.
You're proposing a giant change.
There's a lot of no.
Yeah,
that's not cool.
You know,
you don't,
you don't deserve to be equal.
Okay.
What you deserve as a fair system to
compete in the tax breaks for the rich.
It's just look so shitty.
There should always be
benefit for performance.
That's why what makes human beings excel?
It should be a benefit for performance.
So your ideas,
your socialistic nonsense,
it's it.
It violates human behavior.
It violates everything that we know
about how people operate and how people
progress.
We like to compete with each other.
It's fun.
We like to prove that we're worthy.
We liked to create
things that people enjoy.
We like to put out a bunch of things
and would like to be rewarded for that.
And there's nothing wrong with that.
Hippies.
All right?
Just because you can't run doesn't
mean other people can't run.
Okay?
They want to run.
Let us run.
Shut up.
All it seems like they've succeeded in
doing is getting cops in trouble for
beating on them.
We're all like one man.
They should be new.
Many man,
there should be money.
There's just,
you should be a fair system.
It's supposed to be one piece
of gold equals one donkey.
It's supposed to be,
you know,
it's supposed to be based on that problem
or 1% will still own all the gold.
Yeah,
but so fucking what?
It's,
it's a capitalist game,
you know,
trying to get a cap on it.
I mean,
it wouldn't be bad to
put a ridiculous cap.
Like say you can't have more than $10
billion ever and everything more than $10
billion go.
Yeah,
you're right.
Just fucking give it to charity and
you'd just be laughing in Baldwin.
So wouldn't stop you from,
you know,
you,
you'd still be wanting to make a lot of
money if you were that dude who was out
there,
you know,
I can ask what am I 10 billion.
Most of them don't get like that.
Whatever makes a guy like bill
gates become a guy like bill gates.
Make some,
keep putting in more money and
keep working until they're old men.
You know,
they enjoy it.
Bill Gates could have retired like with
windows 95 he could have just sold that
shit.
I probably would have,
well no,
you need a,
you need a competitor now windows me cause
but the Mac Osx back then sucked the,
I mean not OSX before,
pre Osx,
whatever it was.
Steve jobs started back off.
That's a reason I didn't want to switch
over to Mac cause because their ios nine
or before it was really hard to use.
You couldn't see what was open and
it was just like way harder to use.
I remember when John Carmax started coding
for the Mac when they first started.
Tried to port it software games
or the Mac and he was like,
oh my God,
like she's things are crap.
Like I remember they said there was no
multitasking and the operating system,
no preemptive multitasking and no memory
protection and the things are just shut
down crash.
And it was like talking to me to make
a blog about how many times he had to
reboot,
just crash.
But then they get that Osx and
it became much better at all.
It's dope.
It's like it's the future.
And by the way,
this is only,
you know,
obviously step one,
there's going to be some
new shit in like 10 years.
It's going to make this look
like we're playing pong.
When they did away with the,
with the,
with the um,
uh,
just drive,
I was like,
what are you guys
doing?
The no one's you're idiots.
We got put a floppy in.
We had so many people.
When I worked at gateway,
that was right when we stopped putting
disk drives and our computers and like
you could still,
we,
we still have this external one that
you could like hook up a using USP and
people got so angry.
People come in and goes,
you guys are,
we don't want change.
They want it floppy disks.
They wanted that.
It's works fine.
Why are you messing with the system?
I saw one on the sidewalk the other day.
I wanted to pick it up and I'm like,
I wonder why I'm the fuck's on
this floppy disk on the sidewalk,
but I was like,
wait,
I don't even have a floppy disk.
Hey man,
someday those are going to be fascinating.
Someday they're going to be really fast.
I just got rid of my floppy
disks when I the hoard it.
You just do.
I had some old Macquarie,
like a script on it or something.
I don't think you'd be all ended
up essentially it was like,
Ari,
you're never going to
put this in anywhere.
Just throw it away.
Wow.
Look at that.
I would have kept it.
I did keep it for fucking
20 years for no reason.
I had one,
an old,
old,
old Mac laptop computer that had like,
it was thick,
like a fucking brick and it
was like a big ass computer.
But the screen inside it's pretty
small and it had a track ball.
I like the train track,
I remember of my favorite ones,
but the little none of that look like it.
Like some little ads.
Ibm thinkpad,
that red dot on there
that you can mess with.
So when we were talking
about this iPhone Karma,
um,
the idea of it being a at an
American phone and you know,
you could actually pay for it.
So you're saying that they
do them in Brazil now?
Yeah,
they,
they do them in this
factory in Brazil I think.
I think they just are
mixing it up because uh,
the,
the company that is manufacturing the
four s actually had this idea in their
head like how many they were going to
have to make and they just found out.
But from all these preorders that
so many people are ordering it,
it's about 50% more than they anticipated.
50% more,
the percent more.
So I think what they have to
do is just supply and demand.
Like Foxconn can't have
an extra can't handle.
He can't handle that.
Especially if they're
probably doing the IPAD too,
so they're just that splitting
up the factories now.
But you know,
it's just like anything you do.
Yeah.
It's like that episode
of what's happening.
When Raj got that deal to print up the
Christmas cards and birthday cards and
stuff and then they gave him
such a large order that he,
they couldn't handle it and
they had to go to business.
Was that a quiz?
It could have been anything.
I can't believe you
actually remember that plot.
Different episodes.
Yeah.
I never wanted her to sit.
I'm like,
wait,
the order too much.
You had to go on a business.
I don't get that at all,
but it made sense to them.
They were like,
it's only black people watching.
Just say it.
Probably Jimmy Walker got really upset
after a while and didn't want to say
dynamite anymore.
Yeah,
he hated it.
He was,
um,
he was tortured by it.
I guess
it's,
well,
it's kind of weird.
You probably just get sick of saying it,
but you remember the old saying,
where's the beef now?
Bringing that shit back now too.
Yeah,
it's is long dead,
by the way.
I know.
Long before I met her one,
you met the where's the beef lady?
Yeah.
No one's ever said that.
Ever.
In all the years that woman existed.
So now my mom was an executive secretary
for the Whitney's corporation from in
Columbus,
Ohio.
I had a Wendy's today feel very guilty.
Well,
you don't want,
as far as like fast food cheeseburgers
go pretty fucking sporty.
You feel better about that one,
right?
Then other ones?
Yeah.
It tastes better.
You can tell it's hot.
They just made it,
you know,
I'm pissed off at Carl's junior right now.
He's on the Midwest,
but that new steak burger they show where
it's this humongous steak burger with
blue cheese and onion rings and it
falls onto the TV and it's bouncing and
beautiful and huge.
Yeah,
well,
yeah,
it looked like CGI.
Exactly.
I just got it the other day and
it looked like somebody sat on it.
What the heck?
This is all smooshed.
Where's all the fucking shit?
So they made me a new one
and I just didn't even look.
I just took it home and I opened it
up and in the same fucking thing,
it was just,
it was just like the most pitiful looking
fucking nasty burger and maybe Matt.
Okay.
I've always said that.
That's like actresses.
You get them home and they'll
never look like the pictures,
like their head shots when
they got the glamor shots,
the some,
some actresses or cheeseburgers,
you know,
he's talked to my agent about it.
He said he had girls
sometimes where he's like,
you're a quirky.
If you get this headshot that
makes you look like a model,
you're going to be brought in for stuff.
You'll never book what's wrong with you?
It goes off my glasses on
and they want to be hot.
Two pictures,
best friend.
They don't want to be wacky.
The wacky best friend.
How did the redhead from,
from your show and from
suddenly Susan deal with that?
Well,
the one from suddenly Susan started
hanging around with a bunch of gay dudes,
so you got drunk you to draw that way.
Kathy Griffin,
she's killing him.
She's killing it.
Well,
everybody loves her.
She's,
she's funny.
She's funny.
She's cool too.
I liked her and then Vicky,
she's just,
she does a lot of,
a lot of Broadway.
Really?
It's actually really real acting.
Yeah,
she's an amazing singer.
She's got an incredible voice,
like a really,
I think that's like probably
her first love all the answers,
but she,
you know,
she always does.
She's always on sitcoms and stuff too.
That's cool.
I wonder how they deal with that though.
It was like,
okay,
I'm going to be quirky.
That's okay.
I know it was the cute
girl when I grew up,
but in la it looks a little different.
Vicky had a hot body though.
Really thank you Lewis.
Yeah,
she's a dancer.
She had a hot body and that's nice.
She's quirky,
but she was
the robot scroll by robot.
This high school on the way over here.
Yeah,
and they were playing Lacrosse and all
of these high school girls had their
shorts shorts on.
It was so fucking,
they have the best legs.
Isn't it funny that that's like that?
For sure.
Shouldn't fuck them.
Okay.
It's not right.
You're an old man and
they're young and you know,
you shouldn't know,
but,
but why is,
why,
what's going on here and explain
what's happening to my peanuts.
Whoa.
When do we blend that we make,
we make a cutoff at 18 and that arbitrary
cutoff means that this girl can handle
it.
All right,
look,
I know you're just gonna fuck her.
I forget her,
but now it's legal.
At 18 the bell rings,
we've decided that
enough time has gone by,
the chicken has hatched,
this is it.
It's ready for delivery.
Go run.
And he gets run.
And the moment the clocks takes
12 you can shove your cognitive,
but if you put it in five minutes
before the clock ticks 12,
they could lock you.
Fuck,
rub it on the outside until
12th can't even do the hell.
You can't even talk about it on a podcast.
You can't even have a
talking about it on the,
okay,
so for the record,
this girl that we're talking about is 23.
It just looks really young.
No,
we're talking about is when a person
turns 18 that's what we're talking about.
God,
it's just weird that we
have like a little fucking,
it's weird,
especially when you see those
girls that are 17 and you look,
you look like,
or 26.
I live by a horse stable.
So there's all these really
hot rich chicks that have uh,
that have horses.
So I'll be in Starbucks just waiting
in line and just some of them man with
their little horse boots on and there
are little horse outfits and you're just
looking at,
I'm going,
God damn it.
This is not fair.
This is really not rude.
It's rude that girls
don't get that though.
Girls don't look at 15
year old boys and go women.
Yeah.
Give me that.
Young Teachers Look at 29 year old guy,
30 year old guy.
He was really something like that.
Right.
You know,
because men's powers right
around that age when girls,
they're at their best when they're 17,
if anyone has passed that
you're gone downhill.
So that's why you feel the way you do.
And notice those girls never
look at us and be like,
oh my God.
Is that man boobs a yeah.
You know,
like it doesn't go the other way.
Like little girls do not
like older men in the 30s.
Will they do a lot of listed?
Oh yeah,
they'd been molested.
They do.
And please Facebook if
you have Holla at Ari,
he's the guy to sort out your issues.
Yeah,
I know you've got problems.
Always got solutions.
What's that guy from lost
though than a producer guy?
They just married that
16 year old in Hawaii.
Funny.
As an actor.
An actor.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
He was,
um,
I forget who he was.
He was in lost.
He wasn't like right.
Part of it really.
It wasn't a big part.
But yeah,
the girls tweets are Goddamn hilarious.
Her videos are awesome.
Just don't know if you watch her jean or
17 now and she's talks about Jesus and
it talks about how dirty
and naughty she has her.
Her name is Courtney Stotten
follow this crazy bitch.
I shouldn't call her a bitch cause she's
only six 16 follow this crazy style.
Not the type person,
but all her pictures are her and
her bikini poke at her tits out.
She was also alliteration
way through and Oh yeah,
yeah.
He's just very fun.
Cut and keep the videos.
Listen,
this is like,
this is her,
her updates,
the sugary taste of satisfaction is bliss
inside of yourself and you will be
victorious and then it has a wink smile.
Like Holy Shit.
He imagined that nonsense you have
to listen to before she'll blow much
nonsense.
This poor guy,
even though he's 51 and she's 16 and
he's really shy and he should be in jail
because they,
where did they get married?
Where is that legal?
Vegas.
Powerful.
Powerful Vegas.
I think she's from Hawaii.
And so you're allowed to get married in
Vegas and 16 the weird thing is you say
lost for that.
Yeah.
There will be a national
standard for that.
They have weird ones like New Mexico.
I think a man to boy is
like 13 man to a boy.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Talk to the young boys.
They,
they'll protect them in
New Mexico as a smarter,
I might've made that up.
It's fast
and I really don't know.
I was like 70% sure.
I know it was a fact at one point in
time that one state had that I thought it
was New Mexico and I was using it in
this piece that I was writing about,
uh,
about fucking Catholics and how weird
it is that they take Catholics when they
get accused of child molesting and they
just ship them out of state and they do
it on a regular basis.
And I was wondering,
you know,
maybe they shift them to places where
the laws were different and I'm like,
what law would be different?
And then it finds out that New
Mexico was one that had a weird law.
I was like men to women was like 16 but
men to boy was like 13 and I'm like,
Whoa,
who to hear how your
organization is acting.
Totally making my own connection.
So that's why.
But I remember reading all these
different various state laws.
Like you have to be careful.
You have to drag a girl across
a certain spot that don't yet.
We fucking also take someone under age,
across state border.
Even if you live close to the border,
well look,
it's just going over there like Kentucky
and Cincinnati when they just sort of
at twine,
they're right next to each other.
The Kentucky Airport is,
or this incident in airports in Kentucky.
It's real bizarre.
So like there you who if what's the
agent candidates lower there too,
right?
I think it's 1616 might be 17 age consent.
[inaudible] 18 is right.
You know a girl's 18 she's a little hook.
She's out in her own lettered fucking,
hopefully you've taught her to
be nice and maybe be around,
not going to have a great memory of this,
but it will help her grow.
Yeah.
Look,
everybody's had awkward sexual moments,
you know?
Hopefully she's around nice people
and nothing bad happens to her.
Of course everybody wants that,
but at a certain point in time get a lot
of person to be a person and what year,
what year is that?
Is Not bad to have sex with
somebody you want to have sex with.
Relate to.
Yeah.
Like someone said this to me like,
well you know how you got to treat
your daughters and they start dating.
I go there.
They're girls.
Girls like boys and girls like
boys have boys like girls.
It's my job to make sure that
they see what a nice guy is like.
You know where that question comes from.
That question comes from
the ideal that you're like,
no,
I think sort of sex as
victimization of women.
Well it's also the idea of someone
shoving their cock and your baby.
Okay.
It's not just that you raise this child.
Since there was this little
bit that it's something bad,
but it's going to happen to them.
But it's also you just,
you're losing the innocence of
their youth even if they want it.
What about a guy shopping is talking
to a girl that looks the same sort of
innocence of youth?
Nah,
it doesn't matter if the guy loses,
the guy loses it.
It's like a celebration
when the girl loses
cog in the back of,
you're a parent that is
happening through her.
Yeah.
If you're a parent and
you come outside and you,
you see a foggy car and you peer in and
your daughters suck in some guy's cock,
it's going to bum you out.
Man.
That's funny.
It's going to bum you out,
dude.
I don't even like saying it.
If it's like someone that like,
I know and sort of not
like have a crush on,
but sort of just like as a human,
like if I saw Eleanor fucking below
on some guy in a car and be like,
Whoa,
well,
you know,
this girl had to get permission from her
father to the other end of the valley
signed over.
Yeah,
and her mother and father and no
problem with her marrying this dude.
I don't know was a perfect example for
that is exactly what I was thinking of.
She's just going to be,
she's going to be fascinating,
but this girl is 16 year old.
She's so fascinating already.
She's like,
whatever it is.
She's like often deep end crazy man.
Like if you could get like
a fucking one of those,
those helmets,
the record brainwaves
put it on a chick's head.
It would just be like
4th of July and there
everything just killed it.
All sorts of different directions.
What if the holdings viral marketing,
her 16 year old,
the next lonely girl eight puts out a
lot of tweets that are really Joaquin
Phoenix of hot chicks because
you're just hiring role.
Half of like writers.
It's just a troll.
Yeah,
I don't think so,
dude.
I think she's a nutty bitch.
That's what I think.
She's just a hot young,
young,
nerdy girl.
There's so many crazies now and there
are also employed it now just working.
It's working.
We're talking about it.
We're on this podcast.
Half a million people listening
to this cause it's so weird.
Follow her tweets though.
Who cares if she don't
want to support her?
Listen man,
I ain't giving her anything.
Father's tweets.
These,
these bitches not supporting
that entertain you.
Her videos are fucking hilarious.
She talks about haters and
stuff and she's retarded
to master mixes.
Wild wiggling and jauntily jiggling
myself into jolting jams as I Friskopoly
flaunt a flirty outfit completed with
sexy white seven inch Gogo boots.
Wink.
She got that in 440 characters.
Yup.
All of it.
She gets a little hairy age.
It's probably her husband writing it.
When do you think we're
going to see the sex tape?
Cause it's going to be illegal.
Isn't that fascinating?
This the sexy then if she makes it then,
but she has to be 18 I'm actually Mexican
and you have to make sure they would
have to make sure that she would have
to have a newspaper in the paper and a
clock and as soon as it strikes me night
and she hits 18 he shoves it in there
and just talked to monkey fucking her.
Imagine that if that would be the video,
like there's a count down.
The first five minutes of the video
is just four minutes and 59 seconds,
eight seconds in a porno,
but she's not doing any porn until,
yeah.
Yeah.
Well she sits there great episode of
where their ass up in the air with her
pants on and maybe playing with blocks
on the ground or something with her hands
on her button.
The moment it hits one zero bank slop,
he comes running in like
a fucking linebacker Dick
Right in the pussy that they
should do that and they
haven't done that already.
You know,
they should do it.
Most ridiculous porn producers get on it.
Do you think there's ever anyone who's
done a porn and that porn was the first
time they had sex?
Yes,
for sure.
Yeah.
It must be right.
It should be a brother and a sister,
twin brother and sister.
1159 verifiable,
verifiable.
I would love to see someone have
sex for the first time on camera.
Yeah.
If,
if I knew it was real,
but first time it was not that good.
Right now.
It's just like,
what the hell are we doing
from a voyeuristic standpoint.
It'd be interesting to watch.
We are all about Ari.
I show you my third time.
If you wanted to,
you know your third topic.
It's horrible.
It was last week.
Just get a fucking camera
set up in his house,
ate a bunch of tribulus and got in there.
It's every touch herself taped myself.
No,
it's bad for you.
Did she gets on the Internet?
I never have.
Well luckily it's under
the before the Internet.
Not like the way your body looks naked.
Do I not know.
It just seems like a lot of setup
time and like I just want to fuck.
It's very creepy like when you watch it
a bunch and see your butthole and stuff.
Like if I were to do it again the other
way around you you don't like your
angles.
Yeah.
Horrible.
It was horrible at angles.
You didn't know how to work the my space
days it was on a water bed so it was
just really creepy looking.
It was just butt holes and motions and
bad people have like started up their own
like porn sites too.
There's a bunch of them where it's like
guys and their wives and they would just
fuck on camera.
Yeah,
it was real common.
I remember like wifeys world,
that is one of them is it?
Or they get divorced once you realize,
oh,
I could just pick these,
um,
and make a bunch of money.
I don't mean she mentioned
be the hot old MILF,
but now,
but she's probably like
in her late forties,
I think because this is a long
time ago that this was going on,
but it was all videos of this guy.
He never saw the guy but
his wife just blowing them.
She's just constantly
sucking on the same cock.
And there's another one where there was
I deep throat.com remember that same
thing?
That girl and her husband,
a lot of porn stars to do that.
Like a only fuck this my boyfriend now
that's the only guy that shit's boring to
us girls more or you're not commit.
It seems like you're liking this.
I'm turning out.
Yeah.
What do you mean really
in love with that guy.
How strange.
Horrible Shit.
How's your smoking?
Smoking.
You're smoking buddy.
James James is fine.
My smoking buddy.
That's great.
Isn't it weird being friends with a
porno stars and then you see their work
isn't that strange feeling.
I know you still,
something's happening.
It makes masturbation easier though.
It makes masturbation easy.
You're hanging out with
somebody and you're like,
oh I could actually see what this
girl looks like having sex now.
And that's,
you know,
hmm.
Cause he hung out with them.
Normally when I know when I
know somebody who has a point,
I'll avoid it on purpose.
Like I don't want to fucking see this.
But then I remember after Jaden wouldn't
fuck me that night when I came home I
was like,
I look beat off to you as well.
What happened was he thought
he's going to get some and uh,
she's gonna come over Ariz and there
or you were going to go over hers.
I went over to her place and then
you've got to smoke weed together.
And I was like,
Oh shit.
Smoke weed to Aa with a hot porn star,
so he's like,
oh shit,
it's on kid and she got up there.
She's like already know this isn't,
I mean my panties,
but that's just how I roll.
Most of them are actually
not as horny and got Olson.
The Guy I want to meet [inaudible] seems
like in real life she'll fuck you know
the janitor.
That's what it is.
Do you want to seem like that
Norton shot a load into her?
Yeah,
that's why I actually think he pulled out,
but we think he,
she said that he could've
come inside of her,
but I think he panicked.
Oh Wow.
I talked to Jason.
Jason a podcast.
Let's talk about that too
because you got to a podcast.
It's out on its own now.
It's not under the desk
squad a label anymore.
He got a divorce but we're
all in the same family.
I want to be more at home
and stuff and on the road.
So he got a whole set up and everything
and we actually use that setup on a
plane.
It's pretty fucking cool.
That was really good.
Dude.
Came out like the setup
is nice and I'm going to,
I'm going to start duplicating
that handheld likes
Sennheisers with a cover and
it connects right into one of those zooms,
you know?
But she was on the podcast and
actually talked about going home.
How are you?
She fears arched fear.
Skeptic time.
If you go to,
if you've got to are the
great.com everything's on there.
So what did she do?
You guys talked about it like going
home that night and it was kind of
uncomfortable.
I got,
it was like hearing her side
of it and it's completely fine.
It's like,
no,
I had no intention of ever.
Fuck,
fuck people.
I don't want to fuck.
Like,
oh,
that sounds reasonable,
but we'll have my,
why is my deck still drug?
Listen,
I saw you let that black
guy fucking your asshole.
She's hard core.
I mean have your mouth actually she
was talking about it doing anything,
but again,
she's never done that before.
I actually really wanted it.
That was one of her goals.
She wants to do an gang bang.
She did it finally right.
Oh God.
Yeah.
That was just like how many people was it?
Do you remember?
What is the name again?
Let's find out.
Jaden,
James J j one the normal
spelling of Jayden j a y,
D and porn stars.
Love why and liked mason
like a little girl again.
Let's see which one are you looking for?
Gang Bang.
Oh,
oh,
there's a bunch of one,
two,
three,
four it and it's not that many.
He's like 10 dudes are banging her head.
Is a lot of dudes be fucking a one.
Wouldn't do that in the year.
First of all,
how dare this bitch tonight you after
you see this dairy and he seemed to Dana,
Dana Dearman Gang Bang.
That scared me a little cause she looked
like she was almost about to black out
choking and Cox and then afterwards she
was crying and like saying how amazing
it was.
I just want to tell
everybody that I love them.
I love you was amazing
way for people to see.
Wow.
She's an awesome,
I hung out with her yesterday.
She's so awesome.
She's funny too,
man.
She was really funny on the podcast.
We did the podcast with her dude.
She's,
she's a funny check.
She says,
Funny Shit.
She won't,
he refuses to post on your
message board anymore.
There's a lot of meaning
meanies message board.
There's no way.
Yeah,
yeah.
That's a thing.
Too many people wouldn't
know the right line.
Well,
you know what it is,
man.
It's just that they're anonymous and
it's too easy to just fucking poke.
Too easy to be a dick.
But even that,
you know,
the comments were that late at night.
Some will have a girl on
stage and she'll be like,
it'll be Kevin.
Kind of weird.
And hopefully we're all hoping she
takes her shirt off the end goal,
but somewhat alike.
So whoever's on state,
let's say barest.
Yeah,
Jay Pgi.
Yeah.
And you'll be like,
PJ,
you're ruining it.
Just not understand the line.
We've all agreed on here.
Choose your tooth.
You fucking whore.
Yeah.
Now she's just,
now she's clammed up here.
You have to trust a lot of people.
You can't,
there's only a few ruins it.
Well,
I have,
who knows how many thousands
of members on my message board.
It's impossible to money
if I'm our douche bags.
Unfortunately people got upset that I
said there was a lot of negativity on the
board and like,
here are your mood angry
about what did I said it,
but I said,
I'm like,
there's,
we had a conversation about how many
negative people are on the board,
but you're fucking,
and we're not lying.
We're not lying.
You guys are drawing desert
tiresome and it's not everybody.
There's a lot of really
cool smart people there.
I mean we've met a
bunch of them in person,
like the savage science dude,
that guy's coolest.
Johnny rotten.
Cool.
It's fun.
There's a lot of quick people.
It's not a WIC is great.
I hung out with wicked Houston,
do Wiccan.
His mom,
I drank with WIC and his
mom and Houston and HR.
Yeah,
yeah,
yes mam.
Cool fucking people in the day.
And we did have negative
people back in the day.
It was like one or two people.
We dealt with it now.
It's like so many numbers.
The numbers just so big and
there's some of the MNA influence.
Yeah,
that's a problem.
Those guys come in with that attitude.
Somebody Jewish bags and they
want to get into arguments too.
There's some guys that are
just professional trolls.
Like that's all they do is they just
say things hoping to upset your feelings
and hoping to drag,
drag you into some sort of an
arguments and then you're there.
It's like I got in a fight with a fucking
Francesca Hilton and I was so mad at
me letting my slow sad.
You remember that crate?
She's like John's his
granddaughter or something.
Her daughter.
I remember her.
She was hanging out at the store.
Oh,
why is she crazy?
And then Mitzi eventually made her
a paid regular for who knows why.
That's why she hangs around.
Oh Wow.
Now I do remember it.
She's kind of a big girl,
big just super attention whore,
like needs it.
So she was in the showroom the
other day and she was making noise.
Bears is on stage and he said
something to me on stage.
I'm like,
oh look at Jews coming
or something like that.
And I was like,
I have one question.
Why is she in here making
noise during a show?
I don't understand why this stupid idiot
is making noise and not being thrown
out.
And then I went across
and then while I was on,
she took a phone call
while she's moving up,
the phone rang.
She was like,
sorry.
I'm like,
shut the fuck off.
You fucking bitch.
Shut it the fuck off.
How many people in the audience?
25 30 something like that.
Why don't we just like,
what are you doing here?
Why are you in the show room?
And I'm like,
you're a fucking con.
You need to die.
She would have like,
why am I fighting with an idiot?
Goddammit.
I leave my lights.
I don't think it drawn into this shit.
Your mother's a con.
What'd you say?
All right.
What'd you tell her?
What she said?
Her mom's dying and I said,
I hope you die.
You're a con.
Whoa.
Oh no,
her mom.
I would never talk her mom.
What are you guys talking about?
Don't understand.
Whoa.
Or you needed to sit down
and talk to this person.
No,
I just need it.
Never be involved with her iPhone Karma.
Don't try and resolve issues.
Grow I Karma.
What do you think about the fact that
this person is in your life to move you in
a certain direction?
I felt so bad about it.
I was like,
well,
why did I let her have
any control over me?
I know that's a terrible thing when you
let your anger get away from you do.
She's security guard
and Houston and there's,
this lady was like so rude and would
they tried to like move me through to get
me into the arena.
I had my pass on me and she was that,
I don't care.
I need to find his name on the list.
I was like,
wow,
okay.
It's like the tone and the light.
You're so pleasant to deal with them.
So w got you listen to me
thing and they'll like,
you know,
and after everybody told
them everything's cool,
I show the ID,
ba Ba ba Ba ba Ba got the badges on
and have the names on it and all the
designations.
Finally after that,
she,
she informs me that we
have to wear wristbands.
So she's a,
and I got to put it on you and I can,
can I put it on myself?
I have it in my hand.
She goes,
no,
you cannot do it yourself.
Get,
I will put it on you sir.
And then the guy's like,
you disrespecting her man.
You disrespected her.
I go on disrespecting her
by trying to put this paper.
I go,
you guys are power tripping.
this is ridiculous.
I go,
I'm trying to,
trying to go to work.
You,
you want me to wear the paper wristband?
I wear the paper wristband,
but you have to put it on me.
What the fuck man,
that's the problem when those
people get put in charge.
Exactly.
Like if you're working at Starbucks,
you shouldn't be in control
of throwing somebody out.
It was so gross.
It's gross and people power trip,
you know?
And when people just act like Dixon,
it's one thing as you're following the
rules and there was another lady that we
dealt with on the other side,
you know,
and show your id,
go through the whole thing and she was
very pleasant and the way she did it.
And how y'all doing this
afternoon and be like,
good,
how you doing?
Everything good?
Everything's good.
Let's just check up here
real quick and say your name.
Oh God.
I should know you should not.
All right,
well here's your id going
through and that's all.
You know what best,
how does that,
why does that to do,
I got a security guard,
one of the UFC,
I think it was in Nashville and I was
sitting up in those seats and because no
one was there,
I didn't know anybody there.
And I went back to get something to
eat and when I came back she goes,
do you have a path?
I'm like,
I don't really have one at all.
I to go,
oh,
I'll try to remember you.
And next time I went back there,
I got her a fucking Pepsi.
Nice.
She was like,
you know,
you saw me walking with this guy.
You know,
I'm cool.
It's all right.
You're being a regular human being.
Good for you.
She was totally Rad.
That's the move tool.
You should get them something
cool noticing that cooler
than someone else might
love to help you out and you look thirsty.
That's made me feel joy,
a little shiny.
You exactly what we bring a little
shiny ass to then to each other,
do it.
I'm telling my CT and two weeks,
whereas yours is going to do an Edmonton,
Edmonton,
Alberta,
Canada,
Canada.
Gather round where the comic strip
and what are the exact dates?
The October 26th through the 30th
October 26th through the 30th Edmonton.
Let's summarize this happen.
Let's make this happen.
Can people buy tickets online already?
Yeah.
It's actually the comic strip.ca,
the comic strip.ca.
That's their version of.com
and again for the people.
Slow to write this down.
What is the date?
It is October 26th to the 30th the 26th
through the 30th and what days are you
going to do the CD?
I think all of them.
I'm not sure.
Definitely the weekend.
Ooh,
that's a good mood.
You should try to put everything down,
put everything you have done.
I mean,
you have over the course of
the years that I've known you,
you've rotated acts a few times.
Other times where it's like,
I'm just tired of it.
Well,
you know,
it's funny,
like we were talking about
that one bit that you have,
that you had a line that I said,
how come you don't do lose it?
And you're like,
actually that was from another bed.
I'm like,
Oh yeah.
You're like,
if they're kind of the same bit,
it's just one little
overlap of a lot of like,
yeah,
I'll just say it's like,
why did you come inside me?
I have a few girls in a
few different stories.
Having had said that to me.
Yeah,
both Ainsley and otherwise you're like,
no reaction one is so much better.
Like,
yeah.
At the time now,
you know,
I've been doing that.
I've been recording a lot of my stuff.
I like listening to it like
with a mind with in mind,
like,
can I see this stuff?
And I'm like,
I can't do that bit.
Can't do that bit.
You can't do that long.
And that's okay.
You can do it anyway.
You're wrong.
You can do something.
But when it's,
when it's like a full act out,
what am I getting?
There's a minute and a half here.
Will you just explain it after you do it?
For the poor folks that have this on CD,
what I just did was,
you know,
reached down and grabbed my deck,
whatever was actually a see me lot of
Dane and he was really cool about it.
Oh,
it was like you'd do
a lot of physical cds,
right?
Like that's,
you know,
he's a physical comic.
We've got a lot of audio cds.
I'm like,
what are you going?
He goes,
after my first CD,
uh,
I had to go back and say,
no more act outs.
I can't see any of those on stage.
I real,
I don't know,
honestly.
Yeah.
We were like,
he said,
no more.
God's elect out,
I'm assuming as something like for for
like a five minute long thing where it's
like,
yeah,
this makes no sense and CD form.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
I think,
you know,
he said it would always justify what he
was doing with his words somehow like
you know,
to,
to help illustrate it.
That's smart.
Yeah that's smart.
But some people just love like that.
Just a plain physical comedy.
And even though you don't understand
what the fuck is going on when you're
listening to the CD,
sometimes it's okay,
but here's my thoughts on it.
Like there's some words,
cause [inaudible] had this,
he goes,
when,
I remember when I was listening to cds,
there was some things I couldn't see.
I know he made a funny face there,
but it'd be like,
I love this.
And I was so wish I could also
see it live so I can be there.
But they didn't lose anything out of it.
Like damn it.
I know.
It's a cool funny face.
There's nothing quite so like,
yeah,
being live at standup show,
even if it's a 40 people in the room,
it's still better than any CD
or a special and I think that,
yeah,
and I think that really if
you're going to record a CD,
if you want to record a special,
the real way to do it is 200 people.
That's not what anybody
ever wants to hear.
Everybody wants to do these big giant,
I think that's what this place
is around that 200 people.
It's perfect.
First CD I ever did was
the last stop in Houston.
There was the old last up to 50,
maybe.
I think we got 300 people in there one
day and it goes stuffed folding chairs
off at different level than
like a than like an auditorium.
Yeah.
I mean I just did the uh,
the Verizon wireless theater and Houston,
it was fucking awesome and it's huge.
That place is gigantic,
but,
but I hadn't been Houston forever,
so it was a lot of energy there is,
for me it was like a big,
this is like,
that's an important city for me.
It's stuck in your head.
Like I gotta make a show for these people.
I'm like,
why?
Like I don't know.
I just,
there's something men making.
You're going to go back to
a comedy club there soon.
Yeah,
I might.
I might go back to that comedy club too.
When I'm,
when I put my special out after
I'm done with the special,
I'm going to have to write some new shit
and I'll spend a lot more time doing
clubs and a lot less time doing
theaters because of the clubs.
It's way easier to come up with new shit.
It's a more experimental environment
when there's like 200 to 300 people,
the acoustics at a place
like that must be creepy.
Like a giant place I think.
I Dunno sort of mean.
It's all about the sound system.
Sound system.
So if the crowd is up against the wall,
like if it goes all the
way to the outside walls,
laughter bounces.
I'm making this part up but it seems
like a bounces harder and everyone laughs
more.
But when there's space in
between the wall or the ceiling,
yes.
Ceilings and it doesn't go off as much
because you're not surrounded by this
laughter.
Yeah.
Like I'm,
the perfect example is the
right and a wrong way to do it.
It's COBB's cobb's in San Francisco
calms the old comms was 150 fucking like,
I'm not that into that room.
Everyone was okay.
But it's like the old room build room.
Yeah.
Ridiculous.
It's on a Wednesday.
Did you really just don't
like best up San Francisco?
Great Room.
It was a great room.
It was real small and it was one of
the few rooms that I would do for cheap
because I knew that I would go up there
and have a real good time and I knew
that would be a good place to fuck around.
Yeah.
Work on my material.
And so,
um,
it gave us shitty wage
but make it a good show.
Yeah.
But they want to do
that too at giant place.
Now there are places like four 50 with
a big high ceiling and a bounce bounce
back far back.
So you're really far away.
But it's so cool that
it doesn't even matter.
It's still really great.
Crowds are great,
but the crowds are fantastic,
but it's not perfect.
So there's two places to me that
they're like super important.
Three places.
Boston's cause I started there,
San Francisco and Houston.
Those are,
those are the two places.
So I used to just,
because this is what I did,
my first CD,
that one,
that pink thing on the wall back there,
the Warner brothers one,
I got a deal with Warner brothers.
They were going to like really push this.
It was a really good deal.
And then Disney bought them.
So Disney,
Disney bought them.
Yeah,
it was Disney and they won't have
done that is their heads were not,
they didn't promote my CD at all.
They listened to,
it was like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
The opening bid is two guys fucking
each other in the basement while they're
working out.
Yeah,
I remember that getting pumped.
They heard that.
I mean I wanted everybody
to hear that one.
I wanted that to be the first track.
I wanted it to be something
that I could only do like want,
they would said,
bull,
do you think about doing a song?
I said,
yeah,
I'll do a song.
And they said,
what do you think about
doing like a sketch?
And I said,
okay,
I'll come up with a sketch.
So I decided I want to come up
with something that's so fucked up.
You can't have it anywhere
else else with that.
It has to be,
yeah,
Yup.
We ever rerelease that or are you an ally?
You can still buy it.
It's really hard and it's always
the CD that's not on like,
you know the iTunes or it's
not on anything like that.
Did digital,
I don't,
I don't believe that.
Like I think I've tried to find it a
couple of times and bought a Phi and all
that.
I think there's some good material on it,
but were a better comic now.
But they were still a
really good comic though.
Yeah,
it's good stuff.
I mean,
I was really proud of it when it came
out and it was really proud that I did in
Houston because Houston was my,
my number one favorite comedians
are Sam Kinison and Bill Hicks.
Those were my two favorite guys,
and they're both from Houston.
So for me,
well,
uh,
being able to sell out in
Houston pack this place,
I was like,
wow,
this is,
this is like,
man,
I love kind of say,
ah,
he was the best.
He was my favorite.
I think out of all,
let me see if I miss stuff.
He does.
It makes me just like go like,
wow.
Yeah,
it'll all the so good.
Or all the great guys.
I feel like he just had this
completely different approach.
Like I remember watching him the
first time I've watched him going,
oh,
that's comedy too.
Yeah.
Oh,
the opening up a new club in San
Diego to really just in Hollister.
Yeah.
This is my series in the margin or man,
yeah,
there's been a couple times
where I've wanted down.
Isn't that the one with the song on it?
You're awesome.
Song 50 penny and a like,
I wanted to play that
for people and I'm like,
oh,
I'll find it on it.
Oh wait,
I'll find it on this.
Oh,
and it's not in anything.
Well I'll,
I'll have them put it on.
I'll figure out a way to put it on.
Right.
I'm sure Warner brothers probably owns it.
That's what it is.
But it's,
it's not as good as,
like I said,
my delivery is not nearly
as good as it is now.
It's funny.
Comedies feels like
they've got everything.
Yeah.
Comedy is weird like that though.
I like having something when I was,
you know,
well the same thing as musicians,
like albums of a,
of a band that plays not
with the major album.
And you're like,
ah,
I see where you're going,
but you're not there yet.
But it's still like I'd want to have it.
And that to me,
that CD represents a sort
of an awakening that I had,
um,
with,
with standup comedy too,
because I was doing news radio
and when I was doing news radio,
there was a long time where I
got fucking really lazy man.
And I wasn't writing any new material.
Oh yeah.
They talked about that once.
I was just,
it was just being lazy.
I was just doing the TV show and
when I was doing the TV show,
I'd get tired from doing it.
And then I would,
um,
you know,
I would,
I would fuck off and I
wouldn't write any new shit.
So he's just do the same stuff.
Yeah.
But it might be at my act got
really stale and then some,
a writers from the show
came to see me and I bombed.
Oh,
really?
Yeah.
With the old stuff store.